[Music]
foreign
right what's going on we check these
levels right quick
what is going on
yo Six Flag was going to Christopher
Hart what's going on no bad Celia my man
mostly Martinez what's going on let me
know my levels is good geekhead girl
what's going on a Rodimus you know Mr
Sean Zoo Mojo Blues what's up man let me
know my levels are sounding chilling
just trying to get up early Sunday
morning service a good Lords you know
trying to wake up Sinister what up man
yo my bad Sinister I missed your um your
joint yesterday bro my fault I didn't
know you was doing the raid you got to
give me the heads up because I had some
plans already you know what I'm saying
yeah it's early man king Dobby this
early it's 10 it's 10 30 on the East
Coast like so it's early for me sick
thank you brother appreciate it
six-layer trying to get down with the
fights I see you so he's just waiting
for everybody you know I mean we tested
out some stuff for the back end gonna
make some changes so hopefully video
quality will be better extreme will be
better you know we try to keep it there
for y'all
[Music]
we will be seeing I think I see an attic
moving and grooving the young wolf so he
should be coming in soon saw by scene up
you know I mean so he should be here
soon of course you know the cake gonna
pull up fun topics fun time that crowd
you look gonna be crazy man I already
know see if we can defeat the evil solve
yeah but yo Red Raven what's going on
what's going on but um anyway I will be
most of Cory Mosley what's up y'all come
in and get a good seat in the front
congregation I'm gonna be busy up front
it's gonna be a good one today
we chill I'm gonna meet up we're gonna
see if Ken get in here and then uh get
the rest of the Lords and we got some
fun in here so I will catch up with
y'all in a few
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
okay
foreign
[Music]
Smith what's going on five dollar Super
Chat thank you brother congratulations
podcast we're having 5K sub salute they
will make room no doubt man much love
much appreciated we definitely got to
celebrate that got all the Lord Jesus
waiting on an attic right now he's got a
little technical difficulty we're gonna
figure it out and then we will get
rolling so I'll see y'all in a minute
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the islands podcast in the
Lords of gaming.net episode number 188
and congratulations Lords we have hit
the 5 000 YouTube walk put your hands
together
[Laughter]
much appreciated salute to the rail for
showing the love halfway to ten thousand
so this is good this is love much love
out the realm we already know and it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the round table on the Lord's date and
today we've got cyberpunk 2077
Impressions and performance 343 Halo
infinite updates and Game Awards recap
and Game Pass impact to discuss so we
gonna get right into it so let's
introduce those four horsemen of the
realm and a round table those original
Knights of the Round my co-host Nicole
most my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord attic how are we doing sir I'm
doing pretty good uh considering I just
woke up 15 minutes going pretty wide
awake so uh you know let's let's look
forward to this 1pm man this 1pm needs
to happen yesterday I I am starting my
boycotting IOP and so the 1pm is the 1pm
is is the standard man I want to go back
to this 11 A.M stuff about your football
like I don't care about none of that you
don't care about that on Friday Night
Football I'm joking
see that's exactly why I shouldn't care
I didn't even know they didn't do Friday
night games like I definitely don't care
and I would like for us to get to one
we're Saturday away I mean Sunday away
and then we go back we go back I'm gonna
consider this one this Sunday the next
Sunday
so what have you been playing sir
I've been playing cyberpunk I've been
playing some star Renegades and
I'm wanting to think oh yeah I've played
a lot of Destiny I've actually beat that
right 10 times this week oh wow we gotta
have some sit up man he was bad with us
nobody hit him back we supposed to do
the ring I love being back on Xbox
simple I see how you do the shot just
days I see I see what you did yesterday
I see what you did what because I was
like yeah Sid is ready to play your PC
he's like yeah I'm back on Xbox I've got
to be up oh no I mean it wasn't a shot
at him it's just like on PC like that
like I thought people were bougie and
like like elitists on PC on uh Xbox and
I used to do lfg back in the day it
ain't nothing compared to what they are
on PC they're literally they'll be like
day one literally the day came out we
want 10 clears something went down and
around somebody just joined your bro
what's going on oh yo what's up
a legendary Bill still bro on Facebook
VR and project xcloud and game I mean
the legend himself salute the Great Wall
man what's up brother please throw the
horns put the he gave your back compat
this man is a legend in these streets if
it wasn't for him you wouldn't enjoy
this game pass as much as you I was
actually talking I'm gonna tell you
right now he makes Game Pass possible I
was actually talking to him yesterday we
were talking about uh about the Xbox and
uh product of OverWatch I'm like I'm
gonna have to redownload yeah he's a
beast man
oh he's right is that his character he's
a beast yeah he would love my son right
now on my side I actually have a mean
Mercy tagged with Ryan R but um okay
uh yeah we got big cloud gaming with the
five dollar super attack
my brothers congrats on 5K hit that like
button thank you sir much appreciated
big clown I see you moving and shaking
out here what else we got then we have
drunken ninja with the five dollar Super
Chat able to make the show today gotta
show love to y'all thank you so much sir
hold on
here looking like Ghost of Christmas
yeah I I need to figure out this color
situation because every every slider
that I hit has done nothing to this no
you got the Whatchamacallit you have the
green inside your shirt
definitely going to be like you're gonna
look like a ghost no the shirt doesn't
have any green yes it yes it does you
know it is
the black and white one though yeah but
you see the the little part oh that's
the silver one that's the silver one man
it's making you yeah it's making you
invisible I think
they fight me over this this 11 A.M when
they miss and stuff I think I think you
did but he didn't hear it uh we got
Smitty Smith with the five dollar Super
Chat congratulations iron Lords podcast
on hitting 5K Subs they will make room
did shout out Smitty before we went live
but you did here so we're gonna say it
again but yeah it's a little bad thank
you man much appreciated brother you
already know so that has been it addict
yeah um you know I got some comments I
want to make on uh on cyberpunk but
we'll do that a little later yes sir yes
uh but you know it's been a pretty good
week especially Destiny man people
people always be like addicts you can't
play Destiny all year and I'll be like
watch me
so good that like on Destiny because I
love raids but it's like I said they
they're such gatekeeping on raids on PC
it's unreal yeah and it's like they the
great just came out the next day like we
want 15 clears what do you mean you want
it
know what to do better have the new
rocket launcher now I just make a post
all on the lfg on Xbox that's integrated
to the UI and I got a ray team in like
three minutes
and then I have to see see I'm not like
other people when I lfg I will kick you
it's so easy because then if it like
it's like a pool full of people and I
could just grab any one of them I want
you got too much power sir let's get
ready sir uh we gotta send Vendetta with
the ten dollars which iron Lords
congratulations on five thousand Subs I
put you guys into my regular podcast
rotation earlier this year and you guys
have been amazing and one of the best
parts of 2020 for me thank you
man you have no idea being so much how
much that means to us man salute thank
you for joining the content it's
definitely been an interesting year for
us we're used to like going to events
and stuff and since all that was
canceled because normally like the
reactions you wouldn't get none of that
because we would have been at E3 it's
arguably if E3 would have happened we
never would have done reactions on this
channel yeah yeah absolutely absolutely
so that's what we got and of course we
have our most technical gaming Lord the
solo gamer who lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sostradamus the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bank my man Lord
Sovereign how are we doing sir I'm good
what's going on guys
I'm very 11AM
[Laughter]
um let me take this opportunity to uh
throw a couple people in the bushes
right man let me do that yeah it's a mad
talk man talk yeah it is
so uh let's go back to Thursday in the
iron Lords podcast stream which I was
not you know a part of right
this is why I have to throw let me start
off with with our guest panelists right
oh deaf singer
wandering Dutch oh and our very own look
at it
all of y'all in the bushes because y'all
you have the worst takes imagine oh all
of y'all when it comes when it comes to
me I need you to have examples are you
gonna have to shut up let me hear this
let me hear this they're ripping it
they're ripping into a musical
performance and I'm like who are they
ripping into and I'm looking at it and
I'm like and I'm like
this is why this is why this is why
people believe the gamers living in
their mom's basement
uncultured heathens
because I wouldn't care
but if I gave you some long-haired
pointy head
are you implying that if it was a Final
Fantasy
but that doesn't mean that the only
music you listen to is video games music
I believe that the words that came out
of your mouth where I don't listen to
music with words
I said the music I listened to nine
times don't have words but no it has
nothing to do with video games
how is it listen get out of the basement
and jump in the bushes
y'all need to expand expand your
horizons okay
your soundtracks he
he's being extra for no reason
I say completely out out of character
dude
yeah exactly
take your spanking the way you're
supposed to yes
world does not apply here yes it does
you abandoned
nah yeah
you know you know why dude I grew up in
a hood listening to hardcore that's fine
I know and respect who Eddie Vedder is
okay you can respect
everyone's sentences
[Laughter]
energy today
in person and jam is the goat the
audacity get some culture in your life
now you know what's crazy you guys tell
people all the time yo man this is
plastic it's just games you know if
that's your opinion that's okay now oh
you don't like this music
time
camera game got him looking like Ashley
Larry up in here
good congrats to the 5K to the next Lily
and uh Team addicts wow
what a Savage
I found you guys earlier this year you
guys have been amazing especially King
and his TCO right now I officially
listened to you guys every Sunday 100
it's been the best part of 2020 thank
you so much absolutely oh let me get
John Denver
the Lord's hit 5K and start acting
totally different addict is officially
Lord heaven
you got Speedy Smith yeah well before
that it's another city another one it's
below it it's below it all right let's
see let's see oh did I miss the destiny
one yes I actually read that one to
myself oh I'm sure yes
that Destiny 2 update on the series X is
absolutely phenomenal Bungie did that
thing yeah
even I who hate Destiny have seen it and
oh my God
it's amazing who else we got what else
we got then we have somebody Smith again
with the five dollars Super Chat thou
shall not take musical foolishness
tell them solve the book of Acts like
because you guys are probably some I I
I know who better is too coming from the
hood and that song was garbled
he's an addict he said that song is
garbage
but once it goes back to the the to the
Hedonism of these
non-emotions
so let me get this straight you're
you're opinion on music
if we can spend 35 on Sports but you
don't hear me complaining we
[Laughter]
this comes to my main issue nowadays
this is trash instead of not my thing
people need to at least show respect
what is doing now I like that one I like
that one okay then we got Gabby before
today with the five dollars in the chat
haven't had this much fun on Xbox in
years plus why does sob look like Casper
the Friend
love and respect you all yes I know I
have I have not had time to tweak my
settings yeah we just debuted you know
some new applications gotta figure it
out we gotta figure it out let's send
that green screen please
no doubt so other than attacking us and
call us heathensong what else have you
been doing nothing at all because I I
was in the bushes that I had to work
when I was supposed to be playing
cyberpunk so yeah I I have played an
hour of cyberpunk which was all enough
to like create my character and do the
first little part of the the main
mission the first main mission and that
is it that's pretty much it no doubt I
think we got another Super Chat too uh
we got Jonathan B with the five dollar
super check how are they gonna have a
Last of Us beer but not know that so he
was singing he was singing to you you
know it's crazy enjoying this track
climbing on me had talked mad snap about
that game like just stop it stop it
anyway and of course
chat uh 5K from the best podcasts every
week
and of course we have waiting patiently
The Incredible Hulk of this AKA I forgot
he was on this podcast the excess gave
him the prophet of Xbox King of the
statues divides nothing less than that
premium experience it is the leader of
the fraud alert movement
beloved little kid how are we doing sir
oh my God
this is crazy well I won't be doing my
man talk because I was about to do the
same one I'm just joking no but King I
got to give you props though because
that you're not liking that you know
like that all that J-pop K-pop music I
can feel that I could rock with that
because oh so that's okay
it's got to be your coach
listen if he listens to it in the
context of the game I like that too I'm
not putting it on my Spotify playlist
yeah that was my thing but I love how
Jeff kingley did his thing
well shout out to Anthony Joshua
yesterday the fight and another tomato
can yeah like the weakest heavyweight
champion in the world taking a tomato
can that should have been knocked out in
two rounds all the way to I don't know
10 Rounds or whatever whatever that
boring fight was he was eating his
uppercuts like it was hamburgers wow he
got him out there with his timoth week
George so anytime he fights anyone with
a punch that man is under the ropes stay
far away from Andy Ruiz that's in shape
because he's going to work you over like
a two dollar next
um check this out over here did y'all
see the Maestro this is the next statue
up for king of statues go to golf Castle
X I did a live unboxing there where I
had to pull this baby out of the womb
this baby is heavy is huge and is
fantastic that will be the next statue
up on Kos Kos is up right now and go see
that um
has been very integral in getting stuff
up now and you know and helping out in
the background helping Cog out because
Cog definitely uh had a lot of work on
his hands and shout out to putting up
the um yeah I had the article for you
though I had to text I had to tell you
because they was like yo why are you I
thought I was doing and I was like
I was like this is Battle of the play
this is G4 this is
[Music]
if I could put up all the takes that I
did I did one that was really great
yesterday my Gardener came through and
he decided that this is the day that he
wants to clean the gutters so he cleans
the gutters so if you're here oh I did
hear that part I was like uh Eli or the
real is coming after you he said dudes
hate knowing Joshua he boxed
yeah that's true oh I didn't see it
what's it called all right so um what
I've been playing this week uh I
downloaded it Excuse Me ukulele I'm
definitely gonna check that out
um Until the End wait hold on hold on
what
um
let's go yo the animations it's so
beautiful and and you're looking in the
background you're seeing the stuff
that's going on I'm so happy that this
game came to fruition I'm sorry
um I'm so happy that this game came to
fruition because we saw it in its
Inception and it's uh you know we had
the developers on the developer on we
want him back on with his wife yeah uh
to talk more about it so we're gonna get
into that call it a seat
now I have some issues with Call Of The
Sea and I I think I had to take off the
auto uh HDR okay in that game because my
TV does HDR right but sometimes you want
to put on the auto HDR just to be beasty
yeah so I took it off and then it
smoothed out the frame rate and the game
is phenomenal because it's trying to do
a hell of a lot there's a lot of foliage
there's a lot of stuff even though it's
a walking Sim and it's a sovereign type
of game with these puzzles and stuff I
still appreciate her story and you know
her trying to go find her husband that
was trying to you know find a to fix the
disease for her so that's definitely
fantastic monster sanctuary
oh when I when I downloaded that addict
please play that that's your joint like
as soon as soon as I downloaded it I was
like I think attic will love this game
it's like Monster Hunter
um
ghetto music in it because apparently
that's important
it's like Pokemon yeah and you you're
gonna like it but you get to control
your characters and they do different
things yo it's really good and you put
them to battle it is nice it's it's
really good um Dragon Quest definitely
was playing that I downloaded Haven I
told you I'm not really feeling it too
much that's sliding around on skates and
on that and you know him being the
weakest speeches debater man to the
alpha female I'm cool with that I'm
control I'm fighting myself to play
control the game sucks damn storyline
sucks the control is great you know if
you're a remedy fan the control is
that's why it's called control
you're going the wrong way man I got
attacked a lot of time
I don't care I mean
it's probably the worst game made like
but they best control like it's probably
they worst game like if you're a remedy
fan don't start with this one don't
start with this one don't tell me what
whatever at this point don't start with
remedy okay I don't I don't like the
fact that they drop you in and be like
figure it out
um you really do they really do like you
you start out in the lobby of this of
this um building and they give you no
concept while you're there like just
figure you don't even know why you there
you don't even know if you're on limbo
or Hell or whatever the hell you at this
is you don't even out you don't even
know you don't know what anyone's name
is they don't have way points to get to
any place you're backtracking
backtracking open backtracking through
backtracking the game is garbage
the map itself was horrible
game from remedy yeah
I'm basically gonna tell you it's trash
like it's trash
basically to you it's true you guys you
guys are just highlighting your
inefficiencies well you know what I'm
gonna I put the Highlight all over me
I'm trash too then obviously but shout
out to Phil Dominus Maximus look it's
not being trash means I have to play
control then I will be trash all year
long exactly so shout out to Phil
Dominus maximum it's really expensive
for saving me that 59.95 oh you fools
paid for the game and all you fools that
even knew it was trash and still
purchased the ultimate you are ultimate
trash at no point in time is that game
any good I don't want to hear all my
time watches his entire statement I will
say this I will say this the the story
of quantum break is better oh thank you
yo but the control on Quantum break it
is the worst it is the worst if I can
take the control and put it inside
Quantum break it's over oh my God
does it sound a little longer it's
because the mic gauze trying to shut off
the bike guys have had enough yo we've
got a 353 I did a controller sacrifices
and do me a favor if you can share that
out real quick to Twitter to Instagram
to Facebook wherever you share it out
just do that even send it to a friend
there we go there we go no doubt and of
course yeah we got a few more actually
oh my fault we have Smitty Smith again
with the five dollars I'm part of the
got to my man crew run your pockets no
doubt we have one more no we're good and
I'm a man of my words
throughout the podcast I will drop two
codes in the chat for us in 5000 Subs
much appreciated sir and of course we
got the gaming ninja himself the Shinobi
unlocked Lord Cognito spreading that
real into the Roman IOP not telling what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear a lot of gaming this week finally
man it felt good to definitely get some
gaming man Destiny 2 oh I lost 60 frames
120 FPS Crucible man it feels good to be
home and non-style shout out to the crew
got to see some old faces shout out to
deal with the [__] oh dear God and um
who else uh monkey you know what I'm
saying Mason was rocking out king I
missed you for about a couple hours but
um
yeah I know because it's a schedule-wise
but it's like yo it's just it's just
good man it just feels so good it did
shout out to PVP big fair and no aimbots
and no hacking and just like people make
mistakes now like they can miss you they
don't get 100 Snipes away you know you
know what's crazy I was playing it
yesterday and um we kept getting like
crazy sniped and not one time that I
think yo that man's cheating not one
time because it felt believable what he
was doing like it was one of those Peak
Corners like he missed me the first time
and my my idiot self tried to try to try
to challenge him again and then I got
sniped it was it he got me the first
time yeah yeah shout out to 105 fov
slider just seeing everything it's just
it's just fantastic nvme drive so it's
code in the chat right now you put your
put your way out all the way out oh no I
take mine to 70 and then I just get busy
no hey look if you could do what you do
I like to see that it's stuff that I
miss in my periphery and I like to have
that but yeah like right now the game is
highly on swords for like the raid and
stuff so it's so much easier to to wield
a sword if you have a better filter
better field of view and I think it may
be a problem with my jumping but we're
gonna figure because my jump has been
better because you know my warlock floof
is always terrible but yeah
I will say that fov seem to be improving
helping me on that so um yeah I've been
doing that I've been um gears Tactics
still man still yo addict we got to talk
shout out to Pike confusion he got the
Far Cry 4 codes
I don't mean to jump
real quick but any of you spitters any
of you who really think you got bars yes
hit me in my DM yeah right now
um I'm doing open tryouts for something
that's very important if you think you
can spit like if you're in the mirror
and you're sitting there like
you know what I'm saying or if you're
down with that Chief Keef life or
whatever life that you went to yeah
right now pop smoke whatever you got hit
me up if you got bars I'm gonna slide to
your DM's right now oh my God
what if what's crazy
hit me up at Lauren King uh King David
OTW on Twitter hit my DM up if you don't
follow me follow me right now and I'll
follow you right back so you can hit me
please don't send me no calypso music
you're done
because gears tactics man I ain't gonna
lie to you like when they said they were
adding the jack thing I'm like it ain't
gonna really be it's gonna be the same
game not fam Jack has a whole new
dimension to the game and now you have
technically five characters when you get
them and then how they balanced it is
they've got these new enemies like some
of them are extra strong and they can
heal the group and you gotta really
focus and get them out of there yo I'm
telling you right now like gears tactics
is not the same game like what they've
added to the series X version is it's a
new game so I'm going through a
playthrough and I'm having so much fun
so that I got that going on shout out to
Quick resume allow me four games at one
time you need to try that star Renegades
up but you know what got me though again
I gotta shout them out bro solve yes my
guess my grace bro bro
it's like a all right it's like a um I
can't listen to instrumental music but
you can play a game called
Jesus Christ
anyways he back on that we are the
please join yeah all right you know how
I like we are the police
is actually a good game this is a
kingdom management Kingdom it is
hilarious and every time all these
people come up to you some people try to
hustle you try to finesse you then you
got a war going on there's there's like
Game of Thrones there's a royal wedding
scene that a red wedding scene that kind
of go down you got your family to deal
it is one of the most immersive get oh
shout out to Philly Eagles I gave was
fire yes yo yes my grace is fire like I
I cannot stop playing like that game
made me start cyberpunk late I was like
yo I gotta see what's gonna happen next
crazy so yeah salute that joint and oh
they kill us all they kill us all right
now he go get his camera fixed stop it
you're just working on the cake but um
all you gotta do is just go change his
shirt somebody said he looked like the
ghost projections in Star Wars when they
talk to you I do
but oh yeah man so that's that and then
honestly um cyberpunk you know what I'm
saying getting that on and of course
cash the last word this Friday we had a
fantastic guest on if you like PVP you
want to know about what's going on as
well as what's going on oh Destiny we
had to send it Nomad when he bought this
it was a fantastic show also real quick
before we get into the business of um I
want to send some positive vibes out to
two Lords of the realm that really need
some love so one is our brother Big E
Eric Vargas you already know you know
what I'm saying one of the original
channel five or the balacon Lord balican
you know what I'm saying exactly yo
salute he's been going he's going
through it he's going through something
very serious right now police saying you
love he's he's one of our OG lawyers if
you if you play with us on Xbox you've
seen
so definitely reach out to him also um I
want to shout out to our brother Italian
clowns man he's going through it with
his family so I'm very please reach out
to him he's got something serious going
on on the family side yeah so check him
out send him some and also real quick on
the on the flip side positive news Lords
of gaming.net
congratulations
I saw the royal couple the Royal ring
was placed on the finger the holy
matrimony was set salute Lords of
Gaming's own hectave reverse good kid
good to see you happy brother and salute
happiness in the future and uh slow down
no little Realms no no Lords just yet
just slow down we got time brother
he's a knock knock
babies I want you all right listen
listen listen have those early so that
they can leave faster they can leave
faster
anyway so that's all I got but a song we
gotta take care of some business right
yeah give me a second we had a couple of
superstars
this thing hold on a second let me run
it back a little bit we had the living
flame with the two dollars to attack
morning guys please help me cyberpunk is
boring whoa wow yeah
um that's it so yeah so soft man we got
I think we missed the patreon last week
so yes sir yeah my I I was in Bush last
week and I did not do patreon so once
again thank you to everybody in the
realm for uh for supporting us both on
patreon and on YouTube and uh so this
obviously this is our way of giving back
before I get into that let me know yeah
we got Michael AKA best Dodge Finance
with the five dollars to the chat I
heard orian Doom didn't win anything
sick in my head the game awards or
something else seriously you already
couldn't win anything that's crazy yeah
yeah
then we got Mexican toy bird welcome to
the realm sir Lord bronze put them
questions
for sure all right let me get into these
patreon giveaways guys from the November
8th giveaway I still have not heard from
a couple of Lords Lord Sparty on
um and I forgot who the other person was
but I've only heard from scrub nurse and
that's it guys so please please try to
reach out to me in which way you can
um so I can get you your stuff all right
so let's jump into this ten dollar
giveaway yes
right and the winner of our ten dollar
giveaway is
my favorite news Jesus Christo
Jesus Christ
shout out to Jesus Christ Jesus Christ
the lord Jesus
let me stop
[Laughter]
yeah I didn't get it till I said it in
English
hilarious
[Music]
dollar gift card giveaway oh Jesus got
twenty dollars he just got ten dollars
and the winner about 20 gift card
giveaway is
Aaron Edwards yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's hilarious all right now on to
this Teespring giveaway and the winner
of our Teespring giveaway for the month
of December the final giveaway of 2020.
yes the winner is we'll get the drip Dr
doomfang
that's what's up so congratulations to
all our winners winners uh thank you
guys once again for another year of
amazing support on those podcast has
grown immensely this year um and it's
thanks to you guys thank you so much yo
the chat is so stupid
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah we're all good like I said uh guys
if you haven't reached out to me for
your past wins get at me please because
I don't have ways to reach you so no
doubt so look let's get into last week's
full last week full songs and people
have spoken to the question in regards
to the recent departures of two body
where leads leaving the studio which
BioWare franchise in your opinion has
the best chance for Success moving
forward before I do that welcome King
duby into the ground
salute salute bro put the horns up for
your brother man thank you thank you
Dave so look the winner of our four-way
ILP poll very competitive 33 of the vote
was stop it fam we all know BioWare is
officially in the bushes group wow wow
that one coming in that second place
it's again the franchise the BioWare
franchise that you feel has the best
success moving forward was uh 31 of the
vote was Dragon Age so Dragon Age was
was technically the vote oh well
actually it wasn't but you know second
place third place 24 was Mass Effect the
Mass Effect franchise and in last place
at 10 addicts favorite The Anthem
franchise coming in rounding out that
final thing your thoughts on this I know
you have very strong feelings about our
Anthem and its placement here and about
you know buy whereas Pantheon and
franchises what's the anthem oh yeah
there's a game called Anthony Savage he
already kicking it like it's already
dead damn damn
like like if you guys want I could read
a death certificate but like what what
what is it what what day it came out
that's the DOA day Savage anyway what
day was it announced that's the deal
pull it for Anthony
but anyway so that's what we got look we
should look out for the polls coming at
the end of this show Lord solved man I
know this is your topic it might have
wanted to change it based on your game
plan yeah so I'll just I'll throw it out
there and I'll let the Lord addict run
with it because he's the one who's
played the most but uh yeah I had wanted
to really get at least get our initial
Impressions on cyberpunk uh and see how
far we got in and talk about you know
if the game lives up to our expectations
or you know talk about technically how
it's running right on stuff like that
but again like I said I'm in the bushes
I only got to play an hour of it and
that's not something you like to say
yeah that's pretty much it put it pretty
much I did a real quick King did you get
a chance to play it or
I'm not buying it until they send out
the Next Generation patch if I want to
play Broken Uh current generation games
then I can go do that but I'm not doing
that on the most anticipated game of I
don't know for seven years they've been
doing this in development so you should
have just waited till you had the whole
thing ready I don't care for the game it
didn't come out in my opinion and when
it does launch with the Next Generation
patch the reason why I spend 500 or some
odd dollars plus on a console then I
will purchase it so all you do is out
here cap and yo this one play better
than that one play it don't play nothing
it's playing last generation back a pack
stuff so shout out to Bill still will
for allowing it
that's all you doing is playing the
PlayStation 4 base joint and Xbox One
bass joint y'all all out here capping
and a graphic God I want a emoji with a
dude with a cap and a dude coming behind
him and smacking the camera
this is no cap Sundays
got the next gen patch but we don't I
don't know I'm tired of that I'm tired
of the see always getting everything
first I'm sick and tired of it and we
got to sit here and wait and y'all guys
out here capping y'all should have took
a hard stance and said no we're not
buying and force these killers
you know what sad King is um these
consoles these developers have turned us
into PC Gamers who's waiting all the
time we this is I'm sick and tired of
this oh I can't get spoken uh addict I
believe you have the most hours of
anyone on the panel so uh yeah man where
you at with it as far as Impressions
performance how's it been for you
it's look it's a good game I enjoy it
but
what is that going on in the background
hold up yeah he got some construction
going on let me switch mics okay all
right so while he's doing that
yeah we wait oh well I'll get this get
to switch out while you're doing that
sound better now
yeah okay real quick let's get the super
chat we have uh Bernard Miller with the
five dollar Super Chat Microsoft finally
took my money series X being delivered
1223 can't wait to hop back into Destiny
is that better and continue cyberpunk
the After High stuff was super messy
um no doubt shout out to your central
case stop right here looking like before
school starts yeah yes we heard the
joke's old already Cedric thank you very
much
the thing is like Zoom is is messing
with my camera too because all this this
mad light and I there's no light here I
don't know where this lights color there
is actually a setting that you can train
no and I clicked it and it's not even
reactive yeah is that better yes yes
you're better though I turned it off of
uh that mic because it's more sensitive
oh look look when it comes to cyberpunk
that's a good you know I do think you
know it's a 90 game I think it the
potential to hit a 90 game but like as
far as like mechanics I feel like the
game play like the shooting particularly
feels outdated and it makes me really
value like Vats from Fallout and the uh
the the cryo thing from hold up yeah you
got construction you got all the table
tennis today look I'll jump in um
obviously I two threes I was in so I'm
not gonna make this elaborate you know
thing I'm just gonna tell you about what
I played the thing that surprised me was
you know again I'm hearing the reports
right you here and first of all let's
just get the the elephant out the room
went to King's Point which is you know
we're seeing the current gen stuff you
know base Xbox base PlayStation really
looking spooky out here also
um you know let's call the space Spade
as far as I shot all right is that
better yeah you're better I almost
finished I'll give it right back to you
you know we also got I got a shout out
blamers on ptk blaming the shop podcast
please support them brothers they doing
real positive stuff I like his podcast
but um yeah like I was on a podcast like
we got to keep it real like you know the
Embargo games right you know the the PC
version gets you know it's released out
to the ground but the console ain't you
know and stuff like that and I get it
you know we don't talk about that God
forbid you bring that up people are
going to automatically assume you hating
yeah like we see it with Last of Us yeah
we brought that up with flash stuff like
like it doesn't matter what developer
you are if it's Shady we're gonna talk
about it like man it's just something
that you know these practices that we
know what's going on and I get it you
know but other than that that to me I I
I cannot give that part a pass like I
know what's going on there so I have to
comment on that but as far as like I
said the game itself remember I only
started playing until yesterday I was
told thanks to solve that there was a 15
gig patch right on Saturday I guess so
when I played was on the series X was
smooth was nice I didn't even really see
I think it was one time I saw it but I
would say like a glitch it was kind of
like the character um I was about to go
through a door the character went
through a door or something like that
okay I finally seen something but the
way it looked I was like this look
low-key next-gen to me like I was just
like yo the faces everything I was
really like a tool with it you know when
it comes to how the game looks yeah you
know let me go back to the comment real
quick before these people rudely
interrupted me
um yeah I just feel like the the
combat's outdated maybe it's just me but
like I feel like when it comes to first
person shooters when it comes to these
open worlds that's why you know Fallout
puts Vats in it that's why the outer
worlds of an obsidian they put that like
cryo thing where it can slow time down
because that makes the shooting a little
bit more better
um but you know it's not like it's
horrible it's just I do feel like that
particular part fills outdated let me
ask you this though because I agree with
you I agree with you um you know what
part I'd like that I I think King will
love is Yo the fight in the hand in hand
the hand the hand when you put the two
Hand your king is boxing family you
really getting it and they teach you to
break somebody gone like you could go
dodo with the hands and it's some of the
best hand combat that I I didn't expect
that that's why I said King you got to
give it a shot especially I am when when
when they release the Next Generation
I'm just saying that dude
it's gonna be funny because I'll be like
yo cyberpunk just came
[Music]
like I was surprised how visceral and
good the hand to hand was but I agree
I'm gonna give it back to you attic the
the what you call your answer is that
terrible it just felt Antiquated like
they felt like they do need like a vat
like if you do the hacker class though
you could counter that because you could
like hack something on someone you could
do it and slow it down and stuff like
that but I get a bad deal but you're the
precious one yeah it's like so far I've
played them but anywhere from like seven
to ten hours into it it's a solid game
like it's the definition of what a good
RPG should be but it's just like the way
the game was hyped I don't see
you know meeting that hype when it comes
to especially as predecessor to The
Witcher I wasn't a big fan of The
Witcher but I could look at The Witcher
and I can look at cyberpunk and it
low-key looks like The Witcher came out
after cyberpunk like as far as graphics
and you know a lot of people are
clouding on the graphics I have no issue
with the graphics it looks fine to me uh
I think I think
I mean that's all I can speak on I can't
speak on people with any point it's like
I said on the S I can't speak for that
for the Xbox One X but I could speak for
how bad it is on the S and I'm sure it's
horrible in the S but it's just like I
think it's the art style people don't
like the art style more than they don't
like the graphics there's a difference
between bad graphics and bad art style
and I think the art style is fine it's
just people don't like it they remember
when Crackdown was announced and it
showed that because they have similar
art style looking games like they might
not be you know rock to rock but they do
look similar like I feel like cyberpunk
is what the graphics should have looked
on on crack back down okay
okay it's a solid game it really is the
only critiques I could really give it is
it's like I said the the shooting I I
feel is a little a little weird and
sometimes it could be a little bit
overwhelming but if you've been playing
RPGs for like 15 years like I've been
playing people that's saying it's
overwhelming makes no sense because all
RPGs are overwhelming okay you know he
threw out his uh his credentials
yeah
for 15 years like I've been playing but
this is it I mean you know what it is
this is the thing and I said I think I
said this a couple of months back we
were talking about cyberpunk it's like
they're going to be a lot of people that
buy this game thinking it's a first
person shooter or some sort of straight
up action game and when they hit a menu
and they see what they have to do to
interact with this game right they're
gonna be like oh my God what is this
because it can fool you into if you're
not listening to what you know the the
the dev Diaries and saying things like
that you look at it you're like oh this
is a hot action game right
that's what I was mainly referring to
Philly Eagles said these uh those people
talking about yeah they don't play RPGs
and that's what I was saying it's like
look like don't first off the last game
they made was a hardcore RPG what did
people think this is gonna change right
yeah and and people that come out there
and say I'm not going to play because
it's not third person like what does
that even mean like so everything has to
be third person like I understand people
have a preference right but you can't
it's the same thing that we talk about
the from software argument you people
don't want to intervene and make them do
something they don't want to and when
cyberpunk made this game they wanted to
be a first person so it's like stop
trying to apply your logic into it
unless you're me because I'm at it
but you know it's just like look like
first persons there's people that like
first person Market me me Incognito play
Destiny for 10 years it feels like and
then there's people that like the third
person market right like every this one
let's be real here King this is
PlayStation people saying they're not
gonna play it because it's not made like
a Sony game we can't generalize everyone
no no I'm generalized
I'm generalized
that's what I'm seeing I'm generalized
I've got a ton of people loving the game
I see a ton of people uh trying to be
polarized and talking about this one
plays better than this one and this one
plays this way and I see that stuff pop
up I say this my whole my whole thing is
whatever version you picked you planted
your feet right so whatever it is just
enjoy your game right you just don't
don't stop worrying about the other
people or whoever's doing this because
if you pick the version you are there if
you don't like the version you pick
let's switch over but stop worrying
about everybody else's fun and have fun
with your stuff free [__] bro get tired
of that on my timeline like because I
was just in the chat right and and this
is man talk because I got a couple of
people here let's get it right and he's
a lifelong friends and I'm not blowing
y'all guys up but I'm talking about
lifelong friends and
it got to a point where one was having
his opinion and the other one had his
opinion and that's great to have your
opinions about video games but then the
the conversation turned into personal
attacks really dirty nasty personal
attacks and I was like man facts I said
I don't even want to and I love these
guys I love them right I love each and
every last one of them so I'm not
picking aside I'm not saying who's right
and who's wrong it was both nasty and
disgusting and I said I have to leave
gotta leave man it made me uncomfortable
I know exactly what it was you know
what's crazy too King is like this this
and I'm not even talking about the
general community that we're in but it's
just like the gaming industry in general
like as far as on the consumer side they
become crazy toxic like like you know
what I've noticed like when when they
announced that they did the pre-orders
and they successfully refunded the game
just by pre-orders alone and the people
like oh that's bull it's like this game
came out glitchy I'm like look like
shouldn't have come out glitch it should
not have come out in the state it was
especially Uh current Gene consoles well
at this point passion councils but it's
like I'm not gonna insist on a game to
fail because it came out buggy like like
the people are literally wanting
cyberpunk to go out of business because
the game came out but again let's let's
call let's just call it what it is let's
be real there's a lot of fans that they
have their favorite console and their
favorite game right and the mere threat
let's be real we know cyberpunk was
coming for a while this game was a
threat to a lot of people who wanted
their you know Wanted game of the year
personal title you know what I'm saying
and when these threats come out then
people look at a way to try to downplay
that to make their game seem like the
superior game that's all this is you
know what I'm saying because at the end
of the day if you like what you like
like King said No One's Gonna Move you
off their Square when the other game is
going to move you off your square but
you just can't wait to point out the
floor on the top on the opposition it's
kind of stupid oh I don't look at look
at this on
if cyberpunk isn't your cup of tea then
don't partake yeah right and and my
thing is if if if
you didn't partake shut up facts if you
don't have it in your house shut up and
I know you're like King but you're
talking about it and you don't got it
okay I'm going to buy it when the next
gen patch come out that's my stance
that's your preference on them and also
I gotta bend the knee to everybody that
said that you know um me that because
I'll give you this one caveat and this
is my Hail Mary this is hail Mary no you
know Phil is throwing the ball he's like
[__] watch you King it'll be in there
eventually that's for sure no no no when
the next gym patch comes
so if the next gym patch come out
it's over
it's it's it's like I said man the
game's a solid game and I feel like if
it came out as a perfect you know
perfect Port that didn't have no issues
and I at this point man a massive game
like I do think that they pushed this
out knowing it's broken but there are a
lot of scenarios where these type of
games come out and there's no possible
way that they can fix everything I don't
know why it feels like the the longer
times go but the more blue eyes turn
like
the scary thing about this game yeah and
you are kind of you're fading into the
date against it
so the thing about it is let's say these
consoles these next-gen consoles had not
come out right they laid them right and
this game only launched do you think
they hold this game until next year at
that point or yeah imagine imagine if it
only a base PS4 the base Xbox One game
oh that would be oh even a 1X and a pro
like
um because even then you look at those
games like I saw those DF comparisons
and those game look those games look
Barren like comparatively comparatively
so it's like man man listen it just uh
it goes to show and it I don't blame
cdpr for this because you know people
people take what they loved about The
Witcher 3 and they put them on this
pedestal and what are they gonna say no
don't put us on this pedestal no they're
gonna they're gonna try to run with that
and knowing full well they're gonna try
to outdo themselves with this game right
the thing is uh from what I could tell
so far from me from what my expectations
of the game were
um is that it would integrate the sort
of like I've always said this like the
rules of cyberpunk into how you actually
play the game right into the core of the
the RPG mechanics and stuff like that
and it doesn't necessarily feel like
that is the case it feels like a
straight up RPG yeah
in that world yeah you know the crazy
thing solved it's like I understand this
game's got a lot of negatives and it's
easy to find but like people only want
to highlight the negatives
like night City I've never seen a game
feel more like bro it is alive it's
populated and yeah it literally feels
like I'll walk across the street get
clapped like that's how life it is
day one day one day one I saw people you
know making comparisons like oh just to
compare to the best of Naughty Dog and
the best of yo those games Naughty Dog
games are polished to a t but they're
also fairly linear games
it ain't that it's not that like when
you look at this game it takes that
Bethesda open world formula and it
really tries to expand on it in a way
that is like it's it's super difficult
to straight up hit a home run with that
right and not be buggy and yes could
they have held the game six more months
and have the game come out in better
conditions sure after 100 right uh but
we don't know a damn thing about game
development but we know is that is
no so it's like we know that there's
going to be bugs right yeah uh so it's
just one of those things that's like
when you make those comparisons
sometimes it feels like it's apples to
oranges because this thing even if it
doesn't hit the home run that it's going
for right it's going for things that
other games aren't even gonna happen
yeah
um look
this is an RP this is like an RPG RPG
like this is this is the s's it's one of
the most deepest RPGs
something like Wasteland yeah like if
you're a fan of deep customization
complex choices you know scenarios
playing out in so many fashion and then
to me graphically like when you're
having a conversation the way the camera
pans up on these people it's like you're
really sitting down in the room with
your man you know what I'm saying like
it's a it's a certain level of clarity
against I'm playing on series X I'm
playing on my TV it looked phenomenal to
me you know what I'm saying I did see
like one graphical glitch I get it was
like a clipping it was a clipping yeah
it wasn't like so far nothing broke for
me you know what I'm saying but I'm in
nice C and then just driving the car
going around so you have that aspect
almost like a Grand Theft Auto living
City kind of thing going on then the
inside the corridor shooting again like
I was telling you know um King I really
love the combat like hand I might now go
with a style that's hand to hand because
I didn't think I would like this game
gives you a lot of options for that yeah
like then I was talking to the dude he
was like yo King is gonna love it
because they got a dude who's the boxing
trainer in the beginning and you
fighting a little robot he like yo we
could do this I can have you go around
you know what I'm saying we set up
fights you get this cash on the side
like it's so much going on in streamline
the only negative I will say and that's
that negative I'm gonna say it's like a
pet peeve is that for the people who
don't like or was it first person
you know I did there are options where
you can see your character but I do wish
you could see it more you know what I'm
saying that that kind of because the
game looks phenomenal and the
customization really really does well
but um look man I I'm really liking it
like I'm sitting there I'm just like yo
what are people talking like this again
I'm early though so in caveat let me get
10 more hours let me get you know 20
more hours and stuff like that but um
yeah stealth mainly kills the geeky yes
I'm seeing the stealth you know what I'm
saying going down grab yolk somebody up
yo you know you could do the gnarly you
know you know what uh but you don't want
to be feeling it you're good you know
the biggest things I enjoyed about it
what's your other games have done this
it's not like this is new or anything
but at the beginning of the game you're
sitting there and then they give you the
option this is like the only time I've
seen this to this extent I don't know if
they do it a lot more or you know maybe
not too many more times in the game but
he's like yo uh you know you got to do
this there's a couple ways you can do
this he's like you can either get this
chick to do this to do that to get in
there without a whole lot of going on or
you could just buy it back from them or
you could go in their guns and I walked
and I was sitting on the I was because I
had the money I was sitting there and
he's like well you gonna pay me again
for I'm like nah
and then
pull the guns out there and then I get
up I'm like yo calm down and then it
gives me the option hit him and I'm like
let's go
which is very mass effect based on your
class or whatever you pick there were
conversations because I think I'm from
the streets
whatever whatever right so it was
certain things and then the goals ran
down on us while we was in the Whip and
I would I had like different options
that really strong I'm like yo I'm from
Sixth Street such a side you already
know how I get that let's get these
superchargers yo it's so cool it was so
cool you know what I'm saying to have
again based on my choices whether you do
nothing you play Deus
existence okay no no so I mean it's that
to the next one
this is my question yeah yeah because I
got I got three prevalent questions when
it comes to this sure
um being that uh I played every Grand
Theft Auto and most Grand Theft Autos is
uh not vertical it's just horizontal
right you know so
uh and Deus Ex is vertical but it was in
a condensed you know like uh type of uh
structure they were actually really good
games people yeah it was really good
games like the boss fights both of them
were killing one person it's some of the
hardest gaming I've ever done that's
pretty crazy that's impossible for me
um because I always wind up getting seen
I killed actually I did all the
dishonors without killing people either
I really like stealth games right you're
sick anyway
um
I couldn't do it I couldn't do it and I
know you could
um my question is is it a marriage in
between those two games like Grand Theft
Auto with the the how broad and how
great the horizontal is and Deus Ex with
the verticality and the the intricate uh
Natures of the buildings that you can
get into and go up and go around and I
feel so yeah
from one from you guys this off I mean
what you're gonna say well what I saw
like just a little bit that I did play I
I like to explore and stuff right right
that initial town where you're in where
you you run into that chair up and
things like that I went into like I went
into like the uh the police station or
whatever and I was able to climb up on
top of a uh of a like a like a vending
machine and it seemed like I had
alternate ways of entering a room if I
didn't have the the necessary tools to
sort of just brute force my way through
the door or hack the door or something
like that so it gives you that immersive
Sim thing that Gail sex does that gives
you those different options to address
it right at the same time it does feel
like
that the level of immersion and the
things you can't interact with
is is at another level like in a in in
this way right
asking if you're nomad
yeah I'm Nomad I'm no man yeah in Dex
the world never felt this alive yeah
and that's the thing the the immersive
stem aspect of of deus ex is more about
how you manipulate the things in that
world to to do to get to do what you
want to do right right but that said the
scope of it is considerably smaller than
what this is here this has to be all
things to all this and this is where
they they they they they swung for the
fence and maybe they didn't get there
but it's trying to be all things in a
way that The Witcher isn't The Witcher
is a fantasy RPG it has its set
mechanics this is telling you you're
gonna expect this where you're gonna
expect that way and that's going to
dictate how you play the game and that
is going to be a very different
experience from the next person playing
it completely differently yeah that's
not an easy thing to do so to take to
marry those two genres in a way that
makes sense and works once again it's
like this game is trying to do things
other games aren't even looking at and I
like to see seamlessness between the
outside world and then I feel the depth
when you go inside buildings is still
just as crisp as detailed there you know
what I'm saying because I feel some
games I don't know it's just like in
some games some outside world game
Overworld games get like you know what
structures you can get into and I get it
but it's just the way this is done I
don't know if it's because it's the nvme
and there's no loading now I don't know
something about it that when you go park
into a parking lot go up an elevator
then go up to go down the staircase real
fast
I guess because of the next gen
and me and there's no space it is so
seamless going inside outside and back
out to a world and driving that it feels
real it feels like it's doing something
different that's just to be honest with
you uh Cognito I I kind of thought that
this game was going to take a couple
minutes to look because how massive it
is and then when you're sitting there on
the loading screen to get into the
actual game the first loading screen I'm
sitting here waiting I'm like okay it
makes sense and then like within like
six seconds I think on the the lower
screens like push B to continue
if they think about this at it right you
couldn't even send a text man I couldn't
even slap anymore in the elevator you're
getting phone calls while you're moving
you're doing this you're doing that like
it's a lot going on they've they've
really packed a ton of stuff into this
game and look it's for the people I get
it if people you have experiencing
technical difficulty I'm not trying to
poo poo it if that's your experience you
know what I'm saying obviously current
gen yeah it's just it's not a goal we
can't excuse that it's like look like is
this game perfect no and it's like I do
think think they were being they were
thinking way outside the box and a lot
of things that the Box got a little too
big and then by the time it got too big
it was too late yeah yeah and I think
you know within six months the game is
going to be a complete different game
but it's just like what they have here
is still a really good game it's just
like I myself I was very skeptical with
them because I didn't like the Witcher
that much right but it's just like this
is more my style because it's a first
person shooter and it's an RPG I love
Fallout I love the uh the outer worlds
it it took the good stuff from Fallout
besides Vats I really wish this game
would add something like that and it
just condensed it so much yeah it's it's
something special man like I said yeah
like I said for for people hopefully
that's having the issues you know
they'll get that those resolved but for
me I'm I'm very wild by this game and
I'm like yo I can't wait to see what's
going on the other thing I was just
going to bring to you I noticed your
topic um saw but you know with the whole
you know um did you see the what
happened with a CD project red they kind
of changed their stance so um looks like
they had initially tied the bonuses from
the developers into the Metacritic and
like I guess if they had the 90 or
whatever whatever you know that they
would get the bonuses and obviously you
know the payouts so it looks like
because of what's happening what's going
on they made a change that was mad
perspective yeah so now they're saying
that um yeah because of that they've
because of the structure that they're
going to give out you know the um what
you call the the bonuses still to the
developers it looks like they hit 8
million copies of pre-orders so like
that's one thing I like I just want to
jump in because um for me I've never
been a fan of developer bonuses being
tied specifically to Metacritic it
shouldn't be because it shouldn't be
another Creator can be manipulated it's
not populous and if the populace has a
problem with the company the populace
can sink the Metacritic and therefore
the developers are financially at uh of
beholden to uh fast and you know other
issues you can have king or some of
these you know I'm not saying that you
know any type of bias can go on but some
of these reviewers could be friends with
some of the developers at these Studios
too and they can actually fluff it too
so
but they can be fans a lot of these
we're human exactly right so the level
of anticipation a lot of these reviewers
have for this game coming they got the
game or let's say just say this is your
first game that you got to review right
and you're this is your first review and
you're like oh my God you're excited
about the review that you got to do and
this is your first shot and then it's a
big game maybe you might you know give
it a a a loftier score you know it
should be it should be strictly on the
sale is it the game sold really really
well they should get a percentage of
this that's it we gotta get these stupid
I'm completely forgot we got a ton of
super changes yeah all right come on one
second I got all of them no worries uh
we got drunken ninja with the five
dollars was that able to make this show
today Gotta Love gotta show y'all love
thank you sir
scrub nurse with the 10 super chat
cyberpunk should be a warning to
developers get the game right then put
it out the story inside missions are
great the bugs and getting booted from
the game hurts the immersion story 9.5
out of 10. Wow have any of you guys got
booted for the game I've gone once oh
yeah like it's like but I've played like
10 hours of it I don't think it's it's
like seven but it's probably but it's
just like look like I I agree with that
to a point but I don't regret at the
same time I feel like if you put if you
did everything you possibly could to
make sure that there was no bugs in the
game but it came out and obviously a big
massive game like this yeah your fans
are gonna find bucks before you're
playing testers yeah I can understand
that but scenarios where they stock
console reviews from coming out they
clearly was hiding something they knew
this game was coming off yeah I mean
they knew this game was coming out I
agree when you could you give up
you don't give out the Picasso reviews
for the drink there's a reason but let's
get one it's because they was only
confident with the PC yeah I was the way
they were confident with uh we have wise
old Gaming with the five dollar Super
Chat I put in 30 hours in the cyberpunk
hoping to pass the Oh
blank slider section soon he spent that
much time in that slide effective
amazing how fast the GPU makes it grow
without a building that GPU Iris wow
Jesus
then we have scrub numbers with the five
dollar Super Chat I also think we should
remember Witcher 3 had a hell of bugs
and breaking and getting game breaking
bugs and became the game of the
generation that said there is no excuse
now with the fighter mechanic I think
I think Witcher is still like I haven't
played a whole lot of Witcher maybe 10
15 hours but I do think just from a
standpoint of the world I think people
really especially RPGs people gravitate
more towards like you know the uh the
myth things the wyverns and I think
people gravitate more towards those in
an RPG scenario so that's probably still
going to be the better game because
there's a lot more you could do in that
type of environment that you can do in
this because at the end of the day
cyberpunk is still grounded to a point
yeah well but I tell you this third Plus
in this chat oh yeah please uh those
likes up let's share that out man let's
go rotating this
is 5 000 because of you guys let's let's
keep it above 5000 because of you and
let's let's get it up let's pause and
since we're since we're talking about
since we was talking about dxx uh I got
the mankind uh the mankind divided
deluxe edition
so uh
what
I swear if he wasn't a mod and I had to
go to the IOP to unmod you to remove
that
I am not describing Arc if you ever say
that again
let's go
yeah we got older so one thing to add a
point about that about people liking one
game versus the other oh yeah I got him
okay we um
I do you guys do like big this game is
about introducing people to the world of
cyberpunk as opposed to the story really
mattering like like to the overall Arc
of the story like so far because what
I've heard is like this at the end of
the day the whatever 20 20 to 30 hours
story arc they give you yeah it doesn't
feel like this super significant like
crazy thing as opposed to this is the
cyberpunk world living it right so it
seems like it's one of those things like
I think we're gonna get a lot of DLC
with a lot of content right I think
they're going to expand this world in a
way where it's more about this is a
cyberpunk world this is the first story
we're telling in the cyberpunk world as
opposed to something like The Witcher 3
where they expanded upon it yes but the
single Arc the main Arc was very
important and compelling for that I
don't know I mean I've stayed full I was
on my king with this game like I said
full clear of of a lot of that night
City watch shout out to fans around all
the people like I I love them or those
of my guys because they love the game
but I I didn't want all that level of
spoiling I didn't want I want to come in
for the most part fresh only thing I
want to know okay is the different
classes and the choices in basic
gameplay but as far as the Deep stuff I
kind of stayed away so I I did at the
exact opposite
he's like I don't need it straight into
the information scene
let's get Gotham guy and we got Gotham
guy with the ten dollar Super Chat I
bought the cyberpunk Xbox collector's
edition with the Statue five days ago
but haven't opened it up I'm tempted to
just wait for the next gen patch I
waited eight years already so I can wait
a few more months yeah no see now that
is what I won't do
God bless to you but if it's sitting in
my house the level of Temptation
so you don't even want to in the house
if it was in Game Pass Kings I'd be
playing that right now okay no no no no
the end okay and you're right okay
I'm not gonna lie to you and tell you oh
I'm gonna wait for the patch
[Music]
if it was in Game Pass offer to offer
the respect of the the of the chair
move that fill pool
I would have to purchase
that would have definitely been the move
yeah that's that's me the hypocrite
we got 108 dragons TV with the five
dollar Super Chat The Witcher was the
same way and look at it today every
single game last gen this gen will
always need patches facts the toxic
peeps talk too much shaking my head yeah
this is true let me guess Dan the Man
Cunningham I love that man
what's good iron Lawrence gay
programmers are in a catch-22 they get
death threats to delay the game they get
blasted when they came to the pressure
yeah I mean look I I feel you I mean
they were in a tough spot the game
already got delayed a couple times I I
get it me personally you know when
seeing them current gen versions
you know I'll tell you this and this is
this is on them right I don't know how
they handle this business like whatever
it's not putting dates on it stop and
we'll talk about this in the Halo
segment uh stop putting dates on things
right even just give me if you want to
give me General time frames cool don't
give me a date and they give you
multiple exact dates and it doesn't look
good we got your Stitch hold on yeah of
course we got Stitch with the fifty
dollars thank you sir I've played the
game for over 12 hours on a series X I'm
running graphic mode with vrr to keep it
steady the game has many issues but
still is better than whack it was hard
[__] better which game of the year next
year hate me if you want all right you
gotta let it go brother snitch snitch
okay that was direct shot
um
I told you
I told you when Last of Us launched and
I played it what it was I can guarantee
you at no point in this time and when I
play cyberpunk will I cry will I be
fearful to make a move well I fall in
love with any of the characters well I
fall in hate with any of the characters
it won't move my soul with the music it
won't touch me in the way pause
so at no point in time will it be a
better game hell yeah be a better game
than the last of us too hell yeah for
the simple fact of what it's doing but
it will never
beat the last of us too and heart
emotion and soul
there sir game of the year it is it
sucks that you are mad
listen to kick his focused you gotta you
know then she better you better get a
new follower now and you know I respect
that fifty dollars
because that was a direct shot you know
he was doing what he was doing
yeah we got little Jay Farms the ground
the game on the Super Chat I'm loving
cyberpunk I'm addicted to without fines
you know yeah
then we have John mellage with the five
dollars Super Chat I've been playing on
the on the 1X my wife has claimed the
series X and although far from perfect I
have still been loving it great show
guys
she claimed the brand new toy
rip tiny little oh yeah
all right for real no romy's okay though
wilmie's okay we're just we're talking
about the real the word real the
original The Originals listen
um I'm I'm on my way to recovery I'm
almost there don't think I forgot it'd
probably be a Christmas special where
King actually tries to kill herself
[Laughter]
[Music]
was like wow
now I'm out of here
that's crazy that's crazy
wow look man like we rapping because I
know we've been pretty long on this one
but um look at the end of the day you
know varied opinions it's it's if you're
into RPGs if you love deep customization
you like this if you're coming into it
knowing this RPG you should be fine if
you're coming to a looking for an action
game you might not like it and if you
come into it on a platform that's not
next gen God Bless yeah at that point it
is if you've all if you haven't
purchased this and you only have you
know the Xbox One or PS4 just wait yeah
but shout out to Delilah HD in the chat
yeah check your patch number if you're
1.04 that's what I played on that was my
debut yeah I had no
but it's just like you know I I guess it
just there's so many variables that can
go to something messing up yeah I guess
I hopefully get everything straightened
out but that's all we got on the
cyberpunk stuff uh Lord attic man yeah
up a lot of three four three and drop
some news man
yes the 343 has came out with an update
on Halo infinite and I wanted to bring
it to the realm there's a they have some
updated screenshots I don't know if you
have any of them with you uh Cognito yes
and the game definitely it's looking
like an improvement in terms of an art
style and I just want to you know ask
you guys um because it was a lengthy
update like it wasn't something small
like I I was playing I was playing the
raid on Destiny I was like oh man I got
to make a video on this I clicked the
link started scrolling down like no not
today
is a bit too much here too much yeah man
look so let's get right into it man so
did you get a chance to read the blog
post anything going on with the uh yeah
three four three
I read the the bulk of it man uh first
thing for that first the initial image
at the top of the of the blog post I was
like oh that Ray tracing
photos are looking nice looking crazy
they are still they are still though
they are still
um
but I to me I was glad that whatever has
been going on at 343 they managed to get
together and understand that it helps
the fans to at least feel like there is
a unified message coming out of that
development studio and everyone's on the
same page and that at the very least
they're all working towards the same
goal without a whole bunch of friction
that you know that we that we sort of
seeing behind the scenes right um so
that to me was was it was important that
they did that the fact that it was so
lengthy yeah I enjoyed a lot
and to me the fact that they gave it
there was some speculation that it was
coming earlier in 2021 I'm glad that
it's coming towards the fall take that
year to work on it yeah what are your
thoughts on it do you remember like the
moment that happened I said from the
start no way it's not coming out in the
fall but I mean uh in the spring they're
just like the
pushing it back the way they did if it
was in the in the spring I have every
confidence they would have gave it to
Spring release date when they delayed it
but they didn't they said indefinitely
we come up with something and you only
really do something like that when it's
been delayed more than six months yeah I
feel that so I like the fact that they
gave that General sort of time frame
meaning that they they feel confident
they can hit it but they don't want to
they don't want to sort of put
themselves on the spot giving a specific
date
um that way they can push it as far back
to the end of the year as they really
need to
um so I'm just happy about that I'm
happy that it feels like the game has
Direction
um when they talk about they've been
able to play the campaign through more
than once so and they're happy with that
um you know again that's a subjective
thing uh I hope the campaign isn't in
the mirror again oh what do you have
what happened oh dancing in the mirror
again oh
no but are they gonna get the same smoke
that I gave Spider-Man when it's when
Spider-Man put out the pictures it was
like yeah you know and I was like I
don't give a damn about your pictures
like I really don't I love them I love
them so let's let's just keep it right
and I really when I saw it and y'all can
say I'm captain but when I saw it the
first time I I loved it I didn't care
about Craig I said okay so they're gonna
come with the ray tracing and all that
other stuff you know whatever you know
they said you know patch or whatever so
I like what I saw now for a lot of you
dudes it's like oh that you like what
you saw well yeah so what I'm a Halo
dude yeah right no but the graphics
weren't there well uh also it wasn't an
open world Halo before so now that we do
have that level of open worldness
um I knew I know things have to be
scaled back into a certain uh art style
fine I was cool with it be honest with
you I'm Gonna Keep it a buck with you
like if it was they both said that they
both said that yeah I'm down with that I
know someone did I I know I was there
right so all this updates and when when
when the motion capture dude said yeah
yeah to be out in the spring they're
already putting a bow tie on that you're
the motion capture dude shut up don't be
telling our days
they was running in the streets the
spring I told you it makes Financial
sense yeah and smart a marketing sense
to release the game on its anniversary
tighten it up facts all the way through
Buckle it in get it to
the maximum that you can get it to you
on that date
let them mess up this
let this game come out it is still bad
like like after after two delays because
I'm pretty sure it was delayed once
already what no I'ma say this addict
last of us too and I'm not saying that
Halo infinite will have the soul of last
of us too I just told you cyberpunk
which will probably be the game of this
generation won't have that Soul all
right so I'm just giving you a instance
you got delayed it came out
people some people hate that game some
people love it I don't care about them I
don't care about somebody that hates the
game I care about my one copy that I
purchase right and if I love it or I
hate it it's up to me
they're gonna have something to say
about it anyway right and especially
because it's Microsoft for some weird
reason if a rock is out of place or the
building windows is is smashing don't
look right they are going to have
something to say and I don't care about
those individuals that try to distract
me from my my gaming fun I know when it
comes out people are gonna hate they're
gonna hate when they see the box art so
I don't care about those people right
but I do know
Microsoft and all the heads that are in
charge all of them because somebody's
head is on The Chopping Block here oh I
agree that that's a fish I agree right
that day is very important but if it
meets that Mark and it hits that 86
Metacritic
I know I know what I want 90 at this
point I know what I want but I'm giving
it 86 because I think 86 right now with
how broken the Metacritic is and how
fractured it is where people can go in
there and have Bots destroy your joint
86.
is is is a number that I'm really cool
with I'm really cool with 80 cents yeah
I mean this is where I disagree with
King on this and it's for me Halo coming
back after you know the way people felt
about aspects of five in the story and
the way people felt about how 343 has
been handling franchise right right my
feeling is like Halo has to be more than
what it was right here or back to where
it was right because this landscape has
really changed since Halo was the it
game right right it really changed a lot
so in that just creating game that
appeals to people that love Halo already
doesn't feel like there's enough to me
it doesn't feel like it's gonna it's
gonna do what it needs to do to bring
Halo back which is why you know with the
graphics looking like in a way that I
did not like when they first things like
that things like that where it would
appeal to somebody who hasn't played it
yet or ever engage with the franchise
before
that's where I feel they need to go
that's that and that to me yeah exactly
you give it that spit shine that
somebody who's never been there before
wait a minute let me see what this game
is right and and they've done things
with that in terms of making the
multiplayer free to play and me and
trying to create this this big you know
this esport around it in a way that it's
never been before that's that's a big
way of trying to do that and in addition
how do you get new people to come in and
fall in love with the character of
Master Chief well the story has to be
great and but it has to look good too it
has that thing where you know we talk
about PlayStation games all the time why
do they attract people it's because you
look at it as like oh my God this game
looks crazy let me play this let me play
this so I I think it needed to do that
as opposed to just giving me a Halo that
looked like oh Halo that ran great it
looked like it was playing beautifully
but it just wasn't enough could I ask
you to solve those in defense to what
king is saying like the fact that this
is In fairness you know it's as good as
Halo 5 and for probably graphically
looked you know those were in a box
those were in controlled spaces so the
fact that this is such an ambitious
thing from an open world standpoint and
this supposedly I don't want to say
Living World I don't want to say gaming
service because we still don't know but
does the open world aspect do you
um what's the word I'm gonna say like
make an excuse but do you put a factor
into that as far as the graphical
Fidelity maybe well I think we'll be
able to once we see how open that world
is I guess we could make that assessment
right right the assumption is that yes
you would have to dumb it down a little
bit right if the world is considerably
larger right
um we still don't know what the are we
going to be able to run around this ring
and do whatever we want or if that's the
case I can see that right if it's not
the case where it's still sort of all
you have you can get go to this place
but not this place this place is locked
off you know if it's still that then I
don't know if that argument holds as
much weight for me okay
um but
again I'll make that assessment and I'll
I'll eat crow once the game comes out to
be honest with you so after they
announced well they didn't announce it
but it clearly looks like they're going
towards more of a destiny type of way
when it comes to the story I don't know
how how much extra they're going to be
with I don't know exactly like Destiny I
have almost zero hope in their story at
this point right it's almost zero hope
like the only thing I'm really looking
at right now is Forge and the
multiplayer
let me get my bars off this is very
controversial
um yeah look you know I'm what you saw
in the sense of you know it was
refreshing to see Statin have a blog
post you know me coming from the destiny
world you know I am very appreciative of
you know transparency and communication
right what is going on what are you
doing right we know since we last saw
you eggs were thrown at you
now we need to know if you go got the
courage to get back in his life I have
myself muted because I'm over here
moving stuff around looking for my
memory cards for my PlayStation
memory cards
you know it ain't the PlayStation five
because they don't have a solution you
just got what you got shout outs to
being not ready
anyway so like I was saying like you
know like I said
since the last time we saw that the
other day we got booed off the stage so
the way I looked at it was like okay
what are you gonna do and you know first
step they bring in you know Joseph
stating longtime Bungie Halo uh you know
that one of the OG's you know I I love
to move get that in there and they're
really I mean immediately you know
Chrisley obviously leaves so um you know
we got that part now we get this blog
post and yo like I said it was very
detailed I like how they really got in
front of the as far as the art style and
the whole messaging there and you know
they literally was saying like you know
it was when they showed it to us it was
work in progress we do have confirmation
to back their story down with the with
the dev kits and um we're hearing that
these guys didn't get their kids till in
June right so what we were seeing what
was legitimately as king would say
when it comes to you know the whole Dev
kid stuff we have a little bit more
information than other people it's like
I would prefer them to go the direction
they did and not go the direction I
think that I think that we'll see in
short term we're going to see you know
less performance on the series X but I
have a feeling here at about a year and
a half to two
a lot of stuff's going to be different
when it comes to how games perform on
the edge look at the end of the day
all I would say is the blog post gave me
hope based on what they were they look
good especially those screenshots yeah
the screenshots look fine now now mind
you I like the customization they're
going to give when I I might see the
movie when it comes to rendering stuff
like that like they didn't really show
me anything that I would feel like
wouldn't be possible at all like most of
the screenshots they show they I'm
looking at it now um I'll send it to you
on Facebook if you want to show them
can I share with you yeah I'll give you
a permission okay I'll do that
so it's like yeah like you know the way
the way I see it is you know they even
address they dress Craig he was like he
was supposed to be out there like that
based on where he is at you we can't
wait for you to see him
that was so full gazy yo oh
so full gazy like you know when somebody
lying like I know when a lie is
happening all right I'm not gonna sit
here we didn't put the Face animation
animations in on the secret I was like
man just tell the truth and Shane the
devil we think he was gonna zoom in on
over here
and that that's great but I like the
fact that they at least admitted like
not that wasn't the move because I'm
gonna be honest I was not feeling Aaron
leading leaning into that Craig
I don't love Craig at all Craig
blindsided me and I did not like that I
don't look crazy I don't like I don't
love any aspect of what Craig was about
I don't like Craig even showed up it
peed on My Parade like I was really
running around here running around with
laps and then I woke up to Craig do you
know what that means like that's you
know it is the worst feeling in the
world and I'm never gonna get over this
and when it wasn't exaggerated like the
man had no textures
it was horrible no no we already see
that we should enjoy that
so I mean like you know like when it
comes to like this like it looks like a
multiplayer map yeah this looks a
multi-player
not not that one hold up I think I have
to refresh the whole page I like that
first image at the top of the yeah the
first image and I like the one where he
with the we hold the battle rifle um
with the right yeah the the white and
black drink that drink is kind of fire
but look you know what I'm saying like
oh okay I now know what happened okay
you got it now yeah I know yeah he took
over the whole screen yeah he took the
whole job
this is good transparency is good oh
here we go here we go yeah
see this like this gives me a couple
different things like right now a lot of
multiplayer games are giving me the
option to like what guns and stuff you
use like gears did it yeah and this
looks like something like you'll click
up like this looks like maybe like
something you could see the actual
models I don't think they're gonna do
that I think this is going to be
something that's happened before the
match like something's gonna pop up and
they're gonna let you they're gonna let
you as a team pick where it goes yeah
sure
that's the position
I like yeah I like this one this one you
know what I'm saying with the movement
and stuff like that I like the
difference
and the customers because now this is
like my spark like I feel they really
they see the emotes and stuff I think
they're really diving deeper they did
that before they did it before but it
looks better now that that last one gave
me hope
um
this reminded me of Spider-Man with the
with the puppy
I swear yo listen I'm Gonna Keep y'all
with the same energy I gave Spider-Man
right I sat there and I was giving
Spider-Man all that smoke when they was
posting pictures I'm not gonna be phony
I'm not gonna be fake I like what you're
doing show me the customization of what
the Spartans can look like great but
when you show me still pictures why
don't you show me the VDOT of the man
spinning around show me the VDOT we know
that I'm with you like we know I'm not
coming at you I know I don't know I'm
just saying you know what I'm saying
we're not falling for fraughtery until
the only one that I have that kind of
energy for is this one that's the only
one I have that kind of energy for
because
is a picture on the ring yeah it
literally could be at the highest
settings possible
with Ray tracing
when it comes to like you know these uh
these renders of whatever model looks I
do think the character is gonna look
just like that yeah
it's just this right here this might be
a little
but you see you see all this reflection
like you see even this blue line
This became better not launched and
they'd be like yeah
everybody has screenshot this and saved
it Sony dudes have locked it in they are
ready yeah and they're going to get to
this scene
right here and they're gonna try to
recreate this
if this scene is off I just I'm telling
you yes because we went in on puddles
yes okay and I sat there and I went in
on Spider-Man talk about where them
bottles that joke like and that was my
game of the year trust me they're going
in on you you gotta set yourself up
shout out to Christopher he said I'm
taking it out as you taking out his
puddle game
shout out to pause he said you don't
like the Minecraft looking Graphics damn
fonts but to to be honest the world is
modular it's on a ring yeah even though
the ring is like Earth yeah it's it's
it's still put together manufactured so
at what point in time would it not look
like manufactured and I know what you're
talking about funds let's just see it
first let's just see it for now yeah no
I agree with that though because it is
very easy it's very blocky right it's
just sort of like like you said
manufactured it's very simplistic sort
of architecture I do without crazy
lighting it just looks like yeah like
yeah it looks flat I do think that you
know the fact that they delayed it a
year let's be rare you guys then
delaying Halo hurt them yeah like they
could have brought out Halo in a crazy
position yeah and you know they would
have took the hit but then delaying Halo
shows a lot because it shows that yo
they ain't liking it man like because if
you look at it good everything was
revolved around here
he was going to delay it he said that I
am telling you guys right now 100 I am a
hundred percent guaranteed that they
they had every intention on Halo taking
that arrow to the knee like they had a
hundred percent listen we know the mark
the funniest thing is they would not
sell more consoles
um
there was no consoles somebody sat there
and said from
standpoint
put this game down next year when we
until next year when we have a lower and
that's and that's kind of the the
misthinking that people have sometimes
about console launches right everybody
wants a big game at the console right
financially it doesn't necessarily mean
exactly because you don't have the
installment at the end of the day we get
the better game like take your time like
I was so happy when they set for I was
like good because I'm like that's spring
no fam and I'm with Kings and oh there's
some one dude jumped out of pocket and
opened his mouth I'm like nah they said
bring it out full
I do have some remedies of Hope for it
because I feel like if they're willing
to delay out of the Xbox series X launch
window they're willing to give it the
time it needs to think exactly because
if they if they weren't willing to let
this game go out and die
at the when they need it the most
because the back of the box is Halo on
it they're willing to give it as much
time as it needs I mean they have to
because just like you know how Sony Sony
especially over the PS4 generation right
you can point to any one of their quote
unquote Mascots from their big games
right and they could take the mantle as
the face of PlayStation for however long
whether it be alloy whether it be yeah
Last of Us characters they pass it on
yeah for the 20 plus years that you've
had Xbox it's been Chief and only cheap
not even gears not none of that it's
probably been cheap you cannot let this
game fail yeah
the iconic franchise this is the
franchise what we have guests in the
realm and let me give you the reason why
because you know Sovereign hit it on the
head like uh as far as launching with a
big game in the consoles and everybody's
gonna be like Sovereign that's not
that's not true because they launched
for Spider-Man
Spider-Man with DLC
Spider-Man was DLC if
they were really launching with a real
launch game and I'm pretty sure Ratchet
and Clank is done they would have
launched with Ratchet and Clank there
they showed a lot again
that game was almost done yeah latch it
and Clank is gonna be launch when
PlayStations are available all right
because they they know they're going to
sell out an initial allotment right we
give you the DLC that we're gonna put on
the last gen or whatever I don't think
Ratchet and Clank is going to be on
Playstation 4. they said it was it yeah
so that game is going to be a
PlayStation 5 exclusive and when their
PlayStation 5S available right that's
going to push it and drive it Forward
right so it's business sense right this
Halo is a complete game
we're going to launch it and it's fine
when the game is complete
let me read this real quick I don't
normally not read non-color objects but
you know I'm gonna put on Let me let me
switch mode to my glasses okay
when I saw Craig I was disappointed I
just thought the brute had coveted I was
praying for it oh my God
[Laughter]
oh my God oh we got the medic with the
five dollars in the chat blog post was
great they needed the time they took it
I'm hoping that hail infinite is great
20th anniversary is a better date than
the console launch yeah all right make
an event they can make an event out of
the Year actually
um then we have Eagles fan 76 with the
10 super chat does the cross gen give
you guys concerns for Halo given what is
going on with a CD project with uh
cyberpunk
um that is a good question do you guys
think they're going to drop the support
for the original ones because I mean
it's coming out next year that far out
yeah I think I think the OG you're
talking about the OG I think that I
think they I think they're gonna drop it
I really do like
it was it was iffy if they would but the
holiday they're gonna have at least 10
million units up I think they dying on
that horse no I think not I think
they're going to drop it I think I'm
dead I think they need to focus only on
these next-gen consoles and let that
console die okay how confident how
confident are you I'm confident enough
let's make you do ability
all right let's do it let's do it listen
I don't I don't I'll be excited but we
do it I think I'm I'm rocking with you I
don't think I think they dying they
dying on that sword film they not
leaving that much they're not leaving
that money on it look at you you
thinking they dying on that sword you're
going down
we don't want no confusion
so when this game released Halo Infinite
release
if there is an Xbox One based version
yeah yadi's is mine wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
bass s and X right just just because you
know sometimes
there's no bass oh G you know I'm
talking about PCR Xbox
and if if there's a it's next gen only
then me and solve give y'all give these
up okay right that's what we said all
right it's a fish y'all heard it here
bending knee they're probably the last
but the last ones this will be a fun one
hey little Infinity I'm telling y'all
y'all these is why so you're gonna know
that now we'll know that before here yo
yo listen attic they gonna tell them two
weeks before Oh and that I do believe
they're gonna win to the very last time
and say we do not believe in last year
so I want to chat man I want to chat in
this put a one if you think me and King
got their knees put it too if you think
car gets off got Arnie yeah what y'all
think Chad is there gonna be uh uh uh oh
the current gym for the old gym version
yo you gotta Reach Out
[Music]
I will catch this on my overnight but if
Cog won I'm a boycott for a year oh God
another baby
come on big cloud see that's why we
can't have you back
come on Macho bro yeah bugging yeah
bugging it's done like it's done so wait
wait hold on the two anyways the tools
being that they going for y'all they're
going for y'all oh sir two minutes are
coming for us yeah oh my bad so keep
your tools up so the ones mean that they
go on foreign
[Laughter]
I apologize I apologize I got confused
all right let me see who with me why is
old game okay all right all right let me
see who not with me let me see y'all
you guys got my
God
[Applause]
the treason
order for this game to knock your socks
have to take the boots off
I would be there with you guys if it
wasn't it a whole year
what is four so yeah so look at what
sister with the five dollar Super Chat
you handle release false outside the
two-year support window that was an
arbitrary
if you tried to ride on that I see what
he doing I see what he doing I'm telling
you I mean it keeps it addicts the fence
they could ride the line of well you
know you know whatever they to hell with
that you ain't gotta explain nothing to
nobody what you need to do is put out
the best product the best product is
leaving the old products in the past let
the old products die yo
I know I know murderer
yeah Xbox is listening to me and I'm
saying this directly to you guys anybody
that's in charge anybody can whisper
into somebody else join I want you to
listen to this part it just makes great
you know what the crazy thing is
a reason to purchase that X and S cut
them no oh yeah you know what the crazy
thing is because Phil believes in a
unified system a game pass on all
devices and no gamer should be left
behind because we are the most friendly
companies
Maximus a really expensive once you're
in the cloud he wants you on your phone
he wants you but streaming it
hold up hold up we we got to to make
this clear before we officially yeah
it cannot be streaming capable it's got
to be native on the system oh yeah yeah
okay okay
all right but check out all right check
out this other Super Chat because it
explained it talks about a specific
scenario all right so we got the list
with the five dollars in the chat could
this scenario happen Halo infinite
campaign next-gen only but free to play
multiplayer could be crossed inside 60
FPS
wait that's what happened we all take a
knee because that's one neat loss
he said stop it King you already know
it's guaranteed to be guaranteed to be
on OG platform this is an automatic
bended knee King
look Dying Light worked on the the
previous jig for two years then they
canceled it like we gonna see it's gonna
be some knees and we got new flight
simulator was just canceled on Xbox one
yeah
[Music]
yo first of all if you losing me you
don't need icy
you need a tourniquet sir
we need to call cauterize your knees
everybody on the panel to make sure that
they purchase some some shea butter
y'all want no more ass she needs let's
get big clouds and we got uh big cloud
with the five dollar Super Chat after
the debacle with cdpr I'm with King I
see it being pushing strictly for
next-gen scrub I don't know
whenever they do their equivalent to
whatever E3 s because I eat is canceled
let's just be real here whatever they do
that uh whatever the equal one with the
E3 just like they did in July that's
when they're going to announce it too
yeah oh I got Christopher Hall with me I
got grounded
wants it to be on the OG so it could
hold down the graphic I know what
Christopher Hall listen Chris shut up
oh okay we got one for you pixel bit G
yeah go ahead let me tell you why King
is wrong if the game is on exile the
Exile is still running on the 1s the
game has to be on last then
we just said that it has to be native
Native yo listen pixel I would love for
your scenario like that to be real
please
time let's move on this is the uh it's
like making a lot of fun um soft did you
tally up the uh no I was not there so I
left it to you I saw that I I saw that I
saw that our attic was telling them so
no I didn't tell them oh you did okay I
just want to make sure my Tally was
correct because we have something
unprecedented that has happened is there
is there ties there is a tie
around your lord Gable Woods there is a
tie coming in at 16. with to correct two
people with the correct game of the year
which was now three points this year
are are oppositions of both King and
addict with 16th correct points for game
of the year what the crown with me man
yo we got this it's a king in attic show
we can't I mean we can have a tie break
if y'all
at the end
I'm gonna share this this crown with
King because we're going to share your
knees
we're gonna break up this Unholy
Alliance
the burden of winning
Ebony and Ivory is here I'm still in her
I'm still saying you know what hurt me
you know what hurt me man and you know
what killed me that I would have won if
I wouldn't have done it I was looking at
it why did I pick Wasteland 3 first yeah
yeah that was that was
and I
and I first said I went with the gut
because I liked it yeah but it's just
like man I went in there to win
four guys King did well it was just
there was a couple of years it was the
Among Us for you yeah you didn't pick
among us and we did and it was the final
fantasy for me because I picked
Wasteland you guys picked yeah Final
Fantasy I won't make that I'm still
cognitive yet to win I'm gonna tell
y'all this the ones that I that where I
went with Hades right and it wasn't
going with my heart like I never go my
heart and I tell you why these these
these um Awards right you don't even the
press the Press doesn't have to be sort
of be beholden to be objective right and
when it came to the last of us there was
a lot of talk in the Press about the
negative stuff around all that stuff so
I'm like if there's any place where the
Press is going to take a stand on that
stuff yeah it's here because there's no
repercussions for it no they're not
going to point out who said what right
you can vote with your heart in that
regard so I'm like and I think they're
gonna kill last of us because of that
you know what it didn't happen What
surprised me was I thought what might
happen they sweat yeah you know what I
thought what's gonna happen I thought it
was gonna be everything but everything
right
was right right I thought that thing was
right I thought death scene was right
too because I thought it was going to be
a repeat of Red Dead kind of sweeping
right and got it gotta will come in and
take the joint and you know what right
there at least Last of Us just came in
you know what the funny thing about the
whole thing was is I didn't want that
game winning I didn't think it deserved
that game but it was when it won because
I could potentially win the crown the
Lord
I was like it
it surprised me because like I said it
felt like the year they were going to be
like no we're not about these practices
we're not about this we're going to give
it to the small game and if you look at
Hades from the beginning of development
through on to when it actually launched
like everything the early actions period
people loved all of that it was nothing
negative
and it did it and it didn't and that
that was Bonkers no it wasn't Bonkers to
me at all so now that we've got the
festivities
this is the part where me and attic walk
hand in hand through the crowd
you do appreciate all ovulation time
and I do say it is deservant of Game of
the Year this is the first time the game
awards got everything right
thank you so much I agree with
everything you say King you know Last of
Us it might have had its flaws I can't
even do that
I said yo pick everything last of us too
I don't care what it is
listening
yeah what color you want it what color I
want what that l oh
my God
exited anyway look at this why it's okay
we're King and addict 2021 Nick I'll be
crazy
the votes
[Laughter]
you know what was funny when I was when
we were live reacting to it I was like I
was like man I lost but when we won the
game of the year one I was like over
three point yeah I thought that's why I
was making my comeback I was like
I died with ghosts and the thing I
thought you were you were winning the
whole time I was winning the whole time
and you know what you know what killed
me I didn't vote for ghost in something
they won which was like um
that's why it upset me so much I I like
the waistline three one like it upset me
because I should have picked Final
Fantasy I should have played Arc
direction for ghosts yeah because I knew
ghost was I I was scared
what did Ori didn't win that man I was
sad but then I looked when I voted and
then I was happy yeah what cemented if a
king was picking the among us to those
yeah
I let slo-mo called me into picking uh
gentian impact for mobile game of the
year
no no slow-mo I remember like the week
before they when uh slow-mo and Forte
were doing theirs I was listening to him
talk about getting impact and then he
convinced me and then when we were doing
ours I went with his afterwards I was
like after I saw them one twice which I
lost that and I I'm okay with I lost
that because I would have preferred them
to win that then the people I picked
because they really deserved that you
know it was funny that game ran trash on
on the consoles we should have assumed
we ran trash on the phone
[Laughter]
yo let's get this super chats today we
got we got the living flame with the 2.2
Jack get the tape recorder knees for the
needy
[Music]
two Sage with the five dollar Super Chat
that cyberpunk is a beast Keanu Reeves
isn't phoning in in his performance
people this is officially my new metal
gear solid one from the PS1 days this
game is amazing yeah shout out to Sage
because he put up he put out the story
about getting his his series X and
people trying to be shiesty yeah and oh
my God
yo the FedEx dude had a pitcher and
catch it with some other people and left
it hiding somewhere and Sage was
watching them on his security camera saw
it go down yeah and ran down and it
stopped it from going down but a couple
a couple of more seconds his ex would
have been gone thanks
yo yeah
my box bags yeah it's crazy yeah we got
uh we got Mexican toy bird with the five
dollars so we chat knees getting taken
all over the place wheelchair says about
to Skyrocket the Mexican city then we
got Jonathan B with the five dollars hey
guys I finally decoded stops destruction
the Jedi and trouble everyone reports
the tattoo no no help me Obi-Wan Kenobi
Christopher Nolan give them the award
somebody get the wheelchair so many
knees
shout out to Big clap yeah we have there
we have Fonda Grande game with the five
dollar Super Chat journals and Keeley
foot massagers
Gamers voted for ghosts
the only thing that matters is that
three babies
so what I gotta say is that L though
what color you want
you know
when they did the content creator I was
the one that picked Valkyrie I called
you just like I'm glad we didn't do that
yeah but look real quick man I know we
got kids topic but with Game Pass to
finish up but you know just real quick
as far as like stand out for the show
and stuff like that oh let me give it
away real quick man shout out to 108
um
two two I'm with solving [__]
business-wise it doesn't make sense to
leave that many sales on the table King
You by God but you abandon me and it
will be all glass
I gotta answer him
yeah
let me get that off
let's move on yeah I'm the businessman
let me answer him
um you're gonna get multiplayer
and I mean and that's something that
you're gonna have to deal with I mean
and it's nice because it's gonna be free
to play so you can be free to play with
everybody else but if you want that next
gen buddies if you want to step up and
see that 60 frames with raid tracing
full on and everything looking beautiful
and if you happen to have that cxo or a
TV that could do 120 hertz Mike get you
there I'm in a performance floor I'd get
you there I can't wait to see the kids
regular and the S smiggler is in the
bushes but y'all can definitely
game plus and
any sales on the table but I'm going to
win and we all everybody on this panel
is going to be taking a knee everybody
it's gonna be glorious with you and
addicted I see you there too this would
be payback for the game awards
just just make sure that you shea butter
it up
we all will be sending these to each and
every last one
time all right so look real quick I know
we read an exhausted crowd alone but
just I want to go around the round table
as far as um just the standout games
that was shown anything that you liked
let's do a quick hitter you know what
I'm saying so addict you know anything
that you like that was shown that was
debuted at the game awards I was kind of
disappointed that I missed the uh the
live reaction to uh sephiroth but
um
that was a huge deal it was funny is a
lot of people didn't catch it like when
they did like when he cut the uh the
main antagonists of uh Smash Brothers
and I have yes like that's his signature
thing
and a lot of people didn't catch that
then when the music
I like that I like the Mario silhouette
yeah yeah that was what that was a great
version it was a really good but I think
what probably stole the show was perfect
I like I didn't like I don't really I'm
not left for dead partisan so the back
for blood didn't really do anything for
me uh I think probably the the most
reactionary thing was the the sephron
but like the the the story or the the
announcement of the show was definitely
perfect art yeah definitely because I
mean maybe Mass Effect but you know I
think people knew that was that like
there's been there's been so much
speculation around whether or not
they're working on on um
on perfect art that and then not to
mention you know Aaron Greenberg pretty
much told us not to expect anything
people automatically started assuming
that you know they're not going to be
there anymore
when they did show up with something I
think it really surprised a lot of the
hardcore it was just it was it was a
nice show I really enjoyed it I think
that people are too hard on that show I
think people expect an E3 press
conference from a from a video game
awards last year I didn't like it at all
because I felt like they did too much uh
they did too much oh he went to go to
McDonald's hey you gotta McDonald's like
they did too much of that and this year
I felt like they did a good you know
symmetry of everything and I think it
was a solid show no doubt no no solve
Impressions and standouts I mean
definitely perfect dark when I saw it at
the end I I thought that was uh I'm
interested to see how they had how they
sort of move that game into the 21st
century and what you know some sort of
eco-terrorism thing and how does that do
they keep all her crazy gadgets did you
see it's going to be first person it
seems like it is they no they've
confirmed they confirmed it it's first
person yeah it's first person so uh I
think it's going to be I think it's
going to have a lot of similarities with
cyberport like as far as like Tech to
help you stealth I think you'll have a
lot of similarities yeah so I mean and
they have to make it very different from
Halo uh that was always obviously after
perfect dark zero we didn't really see
the game again but that was always sort
of My worry is like how do you
differentiate enough from Halo to make
it really stand out so that you know
that's going to be a reality against why
I'm interested to see what that is I'm
glad to know what they're finally doing
um after that backflip
yeah I was like oh man the same guy's
coming back to do it like yeah yeah and
it looked beautiful it looked really
good and then after that the one thing
that blew me away which one Crimson dust
yo it reminded us of Wukong this game
doing everything the game do it
everything exactly exactly it's an
everything games the RPG it's the action
game it's an open world game ride
dragons like today that is a good point
uh that I just seen the chat uh the
initial was supposed to be Xbox's answer
to soul to you now it's not are you guys
disappointed it's not the third person I
know King uh Cognito is but are you guys
disappointed that it's not taking that
template well that's the thing like then
who is that's my question if they're not
doing it who is yes I mean you I think
compulsion not compulsions doing one I
think that um
coalitions obviously doing gears I think
that's that's all you're gonna get from
it like yeah it just I really would like
oh wow we gotta answers only but
because I want them to do something
that's the metric I wonder you know what
I want I just want to one time I got Cox
um January 28th what's that what is that
Medium Let It Drop
we don't know we don't I mean yeah we
have hell play too yeah man just that's
not of course Hellboy for sure
and let them make one first person
oh yeah yeah I mean obviously Fable
right Fable is going to be that and
you're not gonna be first person it's
gonna be you got hell played you got to
you still got the gears
you're right yeah 100 all right
I think Joanna dog would have been a
perfect protagonist for that like we
haven't seen a Splinter Cell but they
got a spin-off though
that'd be great yeah the spin-off might
be you know um uh hobo uh Splinter Cell
no I would love to I would love to see
at one day just eat [__] with with with
Phil Spencer saying hey we're giving
it's going to sell to Microsoft I would
love to see that one day because they
don't seem to care about doing anything
but let me address the bar is crazy
people like oh stop the console what
crap why does Xbox doesn't need to copy
Sony y'all meaning to tell me that with
all these Studios
we can't make one of these games that's
the problem like why is asking for one
too much no I'm not talking about y'all
I mean on that on that it just really
mad that I I I got I could beg for one
game I can't do that that's copying so
so we can have every other Studio can
make 75 000 of the other genre I'm
asking just for one you know what I'm
saying and that's too much
understands
Xbox had Halo 360 had gears what is the
new the new next new IP that's that's
all I'm saying like we got to stop
acting like just because I don't that
genre like we can't just make one of the
genre like that's asking too much are we
we can't do what they're doing you know
okay to to to Microsoft's credit they
did it with Quantum break
you know it's not theirs
it's it's no place else
you know at one point no I understand
and then they did it they did it with
the um what was that game that I like uh
overdrive no no the joint in the desert
uh with the with the girls record I
actually like record so maybe they do a
uh expansion on recall but you didn't
like recall but I like I didn't mind I
like recoil I didn't mind it but it's
it's not it's not the last thing is
though what what Cog wants
story driven third first person first
person action adventure RPG elements
with RPG elements that has a deep
evolving story new
IP right that's all I'm saying and I
think we're gonna get it but they did
they did that they just didn't hit
well I'm talking about for the Xbox one
generation like oh well yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying like we we have it as
well
on a break I'm gonna hold on to come on
and break because I thought Quantum
break was really really damn good right
I just thought the the control no no
control was horrible and if they if they
can go do a remake of it at this point
they say because I'm asking for one of
these games I want Xbox to be so I can't
I'm just talking to the chat I can't ask
for one of these games because that's
being Sony this is this is my argument
right yeah I stood here everybody loves
everybody loves what they what they love
whatever the case may be there's still
certain objective measurement metrics
that we cannot avoid as fans of Xbox the
fact of the matter is that the the
Excellence of Sony is measured by those
type of games Microsoft seems to not
even want to get into that room right
and it I want them to be able to stand
Toe to Toe even one time
I think I think my issue with that
statement is is I don't think it's
because like Sony is revealed because of
these games because they're good right
like I don't think Microsoft needs to
worry about any particular genre they
just got to make good games like first
person but they had okay they don't have
games it's on that scale right all right
if they popped out a cyberpunk game that
was on the quality regardless with the
bugs or something people would be like
they they wouldn't care what modes it is
they wouldn't care what person view it
is because look at the people saying
right now I'll I've seen people in the
chat literally say I don't like
cyberpunk because it's not first person
and that and that's the first person
because it is first person it's not
third person I don't like those type of
games so we have to we have to but we
said earlier a lot of these people have
the wrong expectations but we have to
live regardless not you I'm saying you
you guys agree with me but I'm saying we
have to admit that that style of game is
popular right and it is rating high
right so I don't understand why it's
wrong to ask for one not saying that
every Studio that Microsoft has to do
all that no because you could do two
things you can chew gum and walk at the
same time that's what I'm trying to say
like people acting like they just cannot
do that because that's copying so you
got 20 what is it 23 Studios fam yeah
Sony didn't invent the third person
anybody invent that genre this genre
been around for years so why are we
acting that it cannot happen
I guess to me I'm on that I'm on that
wave it's like I just want one good game
I'm like Microsoft do something good
before you try to do what Sony does good
bloody but all right let's look at
something like gears tactics right and
objectively great game but because of
the type of game it is it does doesn't
appeal to even even a large portion of
people it just does it right but the
quality bar is there and and if you're
the type person likes that game
fantastic absolutely fantastic it'll
never get that same thing
they're doing it y'all like I I
understand these other jobs grounded sea
of Thieves like as much as people hating
they're doing these other they're
proving they can be multifaceted all I'm
asking is just for one
yes
technically right multiplayer right all
we're saying is we as Gamers can ask for
one stop saying it can't that I'm not
I'm not fine that's not that's cap I'm
sorry we could ask for one that's what I
asked for one I want them one day I just
want them to stand Toe to Toe and you
cannot look you whatever that game is
that comes from Microsoft that you can't
look at it and be like I got this trash
like you can't coming from I guess you
know it's it's like King said they tried
that all generation they tried to
Quantum break they're trying right with
recore I mean obviously recore wasn't a
good game they tried a Sunset Overdrive
like it's like clearly they can't touch
them at their own game no but but in in
what you call is defense office defense
remember those games they didn't own
those games they remedy they remember
that was the dime magic where we gonna
throw money at it we renting it we don't
own the IP rise we don't own the IP this
we don't own the IP now you got all I
feel like whether or not they own it
isn't relevant don't but remember they
must go Patrol you can't make rise too
because you don't own VIP but you can't
make sense because they didn't perform
well but they don't own them because
they weren't good games but they don't
know
break was good they were on the IPS then
you can actually control the situation
yeah I understand what what solving
Coggins saying and I understand I'm
talking from us you guys are talking
from a sequel point I'm talking from the
games that they got was was revealed
well like the majority of them didn't
sell well
that's also when it was the old regime
right it's still in control right and he
didn't have absolute control so it's the
fact of we'll give you this to see if
this does well and performs instead of
sitting there with a strategy okay we
want this game to happen and we're going
to push it Forward because as I remember
the first uh what was the Uncharted
didn't chart well right but yeah but
they grew it they turned it into
something and a lot of times Sony
releases games and aren't really well uh
they don't hit the first time day is
gone look at days gone right
you do you know and I think days gone
two will be fine fantastic I'm going to
play days gone one anyway I don't care I
wanted to play that you're gonna
eventually have that studio from uh
Bethesda making third person game yeah
yeah hold on a second
um
new okay black Ronin with the five
dollar Super Chat knew it with sephiro
as soon as the music hit he put Mario on
his place that was kind of crazy yeah it
was crazy
not in that one thing try to hit Seth
Roth and he just bowed them both yeah
and we have let me see we have Thomas
Franks with the five dollars in the chat
King may win the bet dude there's a lot
of people telling Xbox to make Halo Next
Generation only pure Xbox posted this
morning
you gotta remember his game pass as well
so I understand that where it's not you
don't necessarily need the Box wait what
um all right then we have Philly eagle
with the five dollar Super Chat I'm just
saying people like different games for
me gears tactics beat every other game
this year so eat to each their own I
grew a cog by the way oh and I got to
give my my joint for the show okay yeah
definitely definitely
then we got JD gaming with the ten
dollars which Microsoft is Kings of
Western RPGs and the first person
shooting but you can expect them to get
that to get that deep narrative game
from compulsion and their second game
coming out of the initiative that hasn't
been announced that's right I forgot
they are working on a second game as
well the rumor is doing what we had
compulsion on so yeah but do you think
they'll go from third from first person
to third person from one game who like
the initiative I don't know
well if they're working on multiple
games at the same time who knows like
again like I I wouldn't do it that's
kind of like a huge turn of events but
they might do it because they got a lot
of good talent these are these are OG's
though they know what they're doing I
hope they do what I think yeah then we
have Sage with the five dollar super
Jack damn FedEx tried to stick me from
my paper
speaking of third person action
adventure Quantum break was one of the
best games of the Gen easy best Journal
yes best story in that game the story of
that game was bunkers yeah I didn't I
didn't care for the the episodes or
whatever but the story overall was great
it wasn't remedy shooting to me and that
bothered
um we got gamer by choice but probably
about Super Chat maybe Xbox is not doing
third person game because they want to
avoid the comparison because they know
that is not what they do best no I don't
think so I I see that's the thing I want
to avoid I don't want to see that you
this narrative that they're possibly
running away from that because
it looked like Roz talking yeah like yo
yo your light son
yes I don't yo it's if I should really
show you how dark it is
overcompensated but Horus is right with
him
I'll moonrise
I hate that majority of Xbox games the
first person I would love to see third
person action adventure games fair
enough I think we have Jonathan B once
again wait hold on oh it just skipped me
I was following along crazy yeah uh
uh we got black Roman with the five
dollars in the chat asked Tony for a
great triple a first person shooter Xbox
doing what they gonna do I get that I
feel him when he says that and and and
and that's true but they still had
resistance and they they pushed all
those games through with varying degrees
of uh um of uh wins between them so they
they still try what what Cog is saying
here is cog wants that real Earnest
effort that they own the IP just give me
that push that Earnest effort and they
own IP and I think they're gonna lay the
groundwork there really what it is it's
about trying to achieve a level of
Commercial Success that those Sony games
gain because a yes there are good games
like addict said but just if you're a
Casual Gamer and you look at Uncharted
just look at it you're like damn that
looks crazy I want to try that you don't
look at gears tactics and be like I want
to try and that you don't because it
immediately it looks like it's more
complicated than it's something it's a
niche game anyway exactly so this is
what I want like I want them to be able
to stand toward the toe I don't see that
beef I don't see the problems with that
I don't mean you just like being a
diverse portfolio being able to do all
these different things and for the most
part they are diverse and I will and I
know the chance except for that they're
more diverse than Sony 100 of them that
like they could do it all I just want
one honest effort on that that's all I
think they're gonna give it to you we
got Dipsy Duke with the five dollars
that's a hood
to Dipsy dude that's what's up man
extra points for the Yankee emblem yeah
for sure you know he's from New York
definitely if Microsoft would make a
Sony third person game the genre might
be dead by then why aren't so many fans
asking for anything other than third
person because they like what they
eating they like them yeah
they're not complaining they like them
why why people still eat Burger King
they like the food
Microsoft owns the quantum break IP and
the recore IP but the developers have
moved on from them and wish they could
get that that's correct that is correct
oh that's correct thank you let's get
that Quantum break
I don't know if they only do they own
the IP or they own the rights of the
first game I don't know but we got it
yeah we got we got something to say
there's a five dollars Microsoft owns
Quantum breaks anything Quantum Breakers
I will put that game story world and
combat up against anything nobody was
made oh jet I don't know about the combo
yeah I'm I'm fall back on the combat but
what I would say is that world yeah the
the story when they got the real faces
of actors that I love yo they had the
Lord of the Rings dude man I don't care
what nobody said well they had little
finger they had ice man yo they they had
they had uh black Chuck bodak
dude yeah from the wife yeah man yeah
[Laughter]
did he looking like Vin Diesel
I got a bunch that got jumped right it
doesn't stop turn your auto HD on that
okay we got JD game with the power loss
of attack cdpr one from third person to
first person and the initiative is a
more senior and talent team they can do
it for sure
ready
no I saw him just confirmed Jesus Christ
man May the life bless you the book of
Acts
it's been chosen
drunken ninja we looking for the answer
we have it with Ninja Blade and
hellblade too yeah Ninja Theory helped
late too late
just for the record
but I would say this if they expand
because it helped late too I'm loving it
I mean I'm just telling you selfishly
but I I know what you're talking about
that fits technically the genre
all right so all right we caught up two
dollars looking like Vin Diesel and
Pitch Black
Rain G4 right we got rain G4 with the
five dollar Super Chat Microsoft has to
give us AAA games that takes advantage
of the series X my man they need to do
it not because Sony is doing it but uh
Us game is dessert
I'm stop telling the dudes making
excuses why aren't you asking them stop
worrying about what and this is and this
is my beef right and this is not I this
is maybe wrong to think this way but
this is the way the market is when you
look when you think about how Sony has
defined what a triple A game is they
look a certain way right so if you're
the Casual Gamer that's looking for what
is the best of the best you're going to
get directed to something that looks a
certain way a third person action game
with beautiful graphics and so if they
don't have that immediately somebody
discounts them right but I don't want
that I don't I don't I don't subscribe
to your theory when it comes but it's
because Nintendo is the market leader
Nintendo is uh winning every NPD and
Nintendo doesn't follow that same uh
philosophy so it really boils down to do
what you do best but add that other
periphery stuff to it and I feel what
you're saying but we got to start with
the narrative just because Sony did it
and they like to do little splash pages
with it it's cool right what what Cog is
looking for and I and I hear it because
I know it because it's been drummed in
my head that he wants one thank you one
you own sure one that you back and one
that you push forward he doesn't want
the one and done but that you don't
follow up but but even that you don't
own even a Nintendo argument though what
are their main franchise yeah breath of
the
Wilder third person three in 3D Mario oh
hey no no no I solved I hear you they
started out in a certain way and what
was selling this gen that's not what
selling this generation I mean breath of
wild is selling like that's not one of
the most anticipated games either no
that was it's for us
for them for for their Market that
wasn't the most anticipated game
Pokemon animal I know what you're going
I know what you're going through right
all right let me get my impressions of
the show really real quick I thought
Microsoft stole the show with perfect
dark but perfect I mean perfect dog gave
me goosebumps all right yes I just
needed them to confirm what we knew all
right so taking that off the table and I
don't want I don't want any Microsoft
person or any Microsoft executive thing
that I'm poo pooing it and throwing it
to the side
it was phenomenal thank you I appreciate
you showing us and telling us exactly
where you were going fantastic
um Sony absence
was deafening it was happening because I
predicted that Sony would be there I
predicted that they would show good
stuff and the absence is deafening and
they're taking you guys for granted
period not saying that they don't go buy
Sony whatever you're being used you need
to realize it okay now my standout from
the show even though all those games
that y'all mentioned was good
Thunder
I don't know which one was that under
was the Tactical x-com type game with
the destructible worlds using look like
unreal five Graphics engine on Steam
hopefully it comes to uh console but um
you pick your uh your team it was like
four guys and you was moving like x-com
and you sending your units out and look
like Gears of War tactics on the next
level it was fantastic that was the
biggest game I took from there because
out of all the other games like uh back
for blood yeah that's great I'm going to
be playing it to death but what's
something that surprised me that I
didn't think that I would see that took
me completely by surprise was Thunder
and I think Thunder is going to be a
sleeper hit when it releases and I know
it's right up your alley card and
definitely up addicts alley yeah
definitely yeah real quick I'll make it
um the show I thought was good for
gaming I mean like I said numerous times
I've not always seen I had with Lord
Kegley on things but look at the end of
the day what this show represents and
what it does for the industry is
tremendous I thought the look was
phenomenal I know people some people
felt a little bit like it was too
commercialized got too popular but to me
look when you got Stephen A Smith you
got all the gaming is here man gaming is
here we're on the biggest stage we're
moving and shaking and um you look it's
good to see as far as standout games
Crimson
um that was in the Crimson joint I
forgot the name of a drag I forgot the
name but whatever that Crimson game is
yeah yeah that looked phenomenal
um you know the sephiroth reveal for
smash was was a Steeler uh show stealer
um so many moments man
um
back for blood you know what I'm saying
Mass Effect you know damn Sean the Liara
again not saying that guarantees that
the game's gonna be fire but at least we
know it's coming back what happened it
kind of pissed me off it kind of pissed
me off because when it was like they
were doing a space thing and I was like
I said it's going down and it was like
Mass effects I was like oh come on
yeah Mass effects will continue yo
Studios
they said the shout out they said the
shout out at the people that left they
was like yo we still got it yo what's
what's crazy is it was like it was like
it was like a breakup in a relationship
yes and he go but I'm still okay but I'm
still yeah
he's like look we moved on but we still
good
bro
yeah this trailer I've been putting up a
good face I put up a good face that they
find and I'm good enough because all I
saw was to happen
sitting there with the half smile like
that means they gonna directly tie it to
the you know the shepherd people that's
the joint I don't want the Rider and the
jiggly legs and the googly eyes no no
Andrea
well we gotta see we got it but I like
that and then damn what's the other
joint real quick it was um it was a
joint it was one over joint oh the um
obviously the perfect dog the perfect
dog I mean at the end of the day like
addict said you know
when I heard Aaron say don't expect
nothing big I'm like oh here we go
they probably told Aaron yo stop hyping
stuff up man yeah
I was like I got you I was mad cause I
was like so we can't get nothing like we
can't get that one is what somebody
working on like you know what I'm saying
so it was the perfect fake out because I
came in like slang on show tonight they
need to do that more often that's what
I'm saying and then they came through we
know what initiative is working on now
it's official super pumped super excited
to see the perfect dog going through
very cool you know what I'm saying and
they had some good announcements but
I'll transition back to you because
we'll combine this topic because it's
yours with the um the Game Pass stuff
right oh okay well yeah it is it's just
very very short very quick it's
something I observed I observed that um
The Game Pass effect is really weird
um in how we perceive new purchases and
games coming out
um I no longer and this is just talking
about me and a couple of people that I
know that I've been talking to I no
longer get super excited
for game releases because
no longer do I have to sit down and
allocate a budget to games no longer do
I have to sit there and say okay well
um these two games come out now and okay
that's a 170 or 150 or whatever it is if
you get their Collector's Editions on
stuff and okay so I gotta pick one or
maybe I can catch a seal I got the two
for one or whatever no longer do I have
to do that because I say you know I'll
sit there and Game Pass I'll finish off
all the stuff that's in game passing
Game Pass have been releasing a lot of
AAA titles and stuff like that and it's
like a smorgasbord that I'm I'm trying
over here and then by the time I do get
around to set games that did come out
because I can miss the purchase because
I noticed that with
um cyberpunk I can miss the purchase and
when I do turn around to get it if it
didn't get released in Game Pass a month
or two later it's at a cheaper price so
it takes the stigma and the feeling of
uh oh I gotta do this and I just wanted
to say that I've noticed that
other consoles that don't have that they
Revere their games in a different Manner
and it's like okay you spend sixty
dollars you must cap for that sixty
dollars you must be out there like yo is
the greatest thing since sliced bread
now if if and this is my hope that Sony
brings that game pass wave over there so
it removes oh that is yeah yeah because
he understands the metrics he sees the
metrics I don't care what nobody say you
got two million they got 20 million it's
a difference it's a huge difference in
how when we started off first he got
some control that does it happen and
does it change because with me I've
noticed that I can fall back off of
purchases more willingly now because of
Game Pass and I want to know if if
that's a thing is is it just me is it
just the people that I'm talking to or
or or what's going on no I mean you know
I I jump in real quick and then I like I
like to stop it I mean I think it's I
get where you're going because it's so
much value in the service and then it's
kind of like yo I could wait because
it's like there's so much quality in
there like it's insane you know what I'm
saying so I I get what you're saying I
mean I don't
I don't know like I I it's tough me
because there's some games that I'm like
yo I don't care I'm not waiting you know
what I'm saying but I will say with Game
Pass being as robust and all these
announcements that we got in there it
does make you like yo you know what I'm
saying like I'm good like I don't think
that you know are we talking about Game
Pass yeah yeah
I never sorry I was dealing with work
stuff that's why I was gone for a couple
seconds I never would have played Stars
Renegade I'm not gonna even sit here and
try to front like that I would have
never played that yes by Grace game ever
I played moonlighters because they sent
me a review code but if I never would
have got the review code I never would
have played moonlighters and that's on
Game Pass like there are gyms that are
better than Triple A titles on gameplay
my premise is is Game Pass allowing you
to wait on certain games until either
the price drops or it comes the game
pass or it get you see a sale on it or
stuff like that is it hitting you in
that effect that the Game Pass effect is
allowing you to hold off and to curb
your addiction while you can play other
games and wait for Price drops and
something like that I think Game Pass is
like you know I'm not as extra as you
like I ain't playing that unless it only
comes out again yeah like what game
passes showed me it's like look like
first off it showed me that these Indie
Games hitting different and people won't
give them enough times and game PASS
gives me the option to play them as long
as I've subscribed to Game Pass right it
also gives me that oh you bored just
pull up what's on Game Pass like and
what's funny is Game Pass Me making my
backlog longer yeah it's just like
instead of playing the games I have put
money into like yo because again I'm
that quick resume is a fun feature right
and I'm looking at I got Gears tactics
yes best by Grace until the end and I'm
like yo I don't even want to touch
cyberpunk just yet because I'm not
finished with these because I'm have a
crazy fun with these games and I don't
think I was gonna have so much fun with
so it's like I get with Atticus save
because it's like it it adds to your
backlog then you there's so many gems
that you missed out on right and you're
like yo I never played that game and I
wasn't gonna get that game necessarily
you know 60 at the time other games were
out so it make it helps with your
business decisions man like it really
does it it it has made my backlog more
you know what I'm saying and I didn't
think that it's kind of crazy
for me it has kind of a different effect
oh because I I Love Game Pass I'll never
give it up right but as little time as I
have to play games the smaller stuff is
why you always see me buying the smaller
games that I want to play that are on
Game Pass I buy them on the switch
because I'm not home right where I want
to engage with those games and I don't
have the chance to sit down and play
them so I do that so in a way what game
pass does to me it's kind of sitting
there all the time to the big
Blockbuster comes out and it sort of
makes me feel like the King's Point
about you don't feel super excited for
the big releases because you know it's
just going to be there it reminds me of
how I started to feel back in the like
the OG Xbox games and the 360 days when
let's just say I had access to
everything
um
you like when the game comes out you
don't care anymore because like I have
it like it was and it's the same feeling
it's not for the same reasons right but
it is sort of the same feeling and I'm
like damn I don't get to engage with 90
of the hot stuff that comes on here
I know what you're you're right you're
right I know where you're going
I do feel I'm gonna have to lend you my
Razor Kishi
because when you get that Kishi and you
playing that xcloud and oh and you
continue it on but this is my thing
though the quiche is not the problem
because of my job
I'm never in a place
yeah so that again I would have told you
if if if the 5G and whatever the Wi-Fi
were viable in a real way through
so it's like otherwise I would have been
on that yeah
when I still came on I got that kissy
oh I already know the experiences
you notice that he hasn't been talking
about
and I knew it was happening I knew that
ice box right now is in a vaccination
chamber
instead of vaccination
yeah
hold on a second let me oh well that's
the last one I'll leave right there
we're at the wise World gamer yeah
today's been crazy man oh my God we got
a wise old Gamers
okay okay no I got it don't worry about
it I have a
alone he's waiting for the new gdks
you yeah we have to even my choices the
five dollars it feels like people want
8K to make Big Mac with Xbox and PS5
maybe Xbox is not confident in their
third person story driven game just yet
just make one just make one yeah
Laura I can see the angel wings the sun
brother no do not accept stay your ass
in your chair pause
there we have uh 72 with the following
Jack the only major game Xbox has that's
the first person this first person is
Halo uh
foreign
CD3 Fable are all third person games
where are all these IP games at first
person
first person Games first person games
well almost everything Bethesda makes
first person exactly exactly so and
that's almost now that's their their
library now Dishonored first person all
the Skyrim games are first person I
think it jumped me and we got a black
Ronin with the five dollar Super Chat
Callisto protocol could be our next-gen
Dead Space yeah that's one we forgot I
mean I saw it
um I'm see listen guys I don't really
care too hard with these CG trailers
game I'm sorry I mean you know back for
blood that definitely showed me what the
game is you know what I can look forward
to you know when barbadwon jumps out the
ground and you run it for your life and
you got one on Willie smacking you silly
in the street wow you got that spider
spitting on your legs
staggers them cast time stop stack
bullets for more impact Speed Dash but
mid Dash pull left trigger it triggers
bullet time with badass one hand on gun
animation
you know what I'm saying I'm gonna go
back I want to go back to Quantum break
on the series X to see a how it runs
right yeah I want to see that so you've
kind of convinced me to do that um we
got the wise old game with the five
dollars I see your family's 2020. just
get uh you just opening The Matrix of
leadership tonight
it is crazy of what it's doing it it is
doing when I tell you how dark my room
is
enemies in Quantum break are more
aggressive
hey you know what I'm saying
mama ain't safe no other third person uh
game can you go into the middle of all
uh Chris Crossing fire and yes you can
go back and forth in between enemies yes
it's a better game than control but I
don't know about that combat it's next
year next week you can go all along man
but stop the Super Chat so we can get
out of here because I gotta go to work
damn it oh then we have Ace akw with 5.5
pounds Super Chat I know what you're
talking about King no longer I buy games
because the game pack yeah thank you
this is that's that's my whole my whole
thing does it allow time let's keep
going
and and to you know just to partake
because I'm playing unruly Heroes I feel
like and that's like rain man on
steroids come on shout out to Wildwood
song but like he in the Bone
Thugs-N-Harmony Crossroads
Iron Mike
[Music]
makes you an enlightened gamer by by the
Light by the light shining on me oh then
we got stage one together
there's also a Splinter Cell conviction
last of us too uh last known position
mechanic that makes enemies lose sight
of you in search that's Time Rush yeah
Quantum break
fire up I'ma download
Let's do let's start doing our intro
outros before he comes back we're gonna
be all night we got 380 here let's close
this show out on 300 likes at least
let's hit that you know it helps us with
the Matrix whatever
you share that out to people please
share it out to your friends I mean if
your friend is sitting there bored and
he's like man you know I hate what's
going on in the world yo show them us
we'll put a smile on his face
I do want to stay you know uh Shameless
plug I'm not we're actually gonna a lot
of people have been wanting us to play
games like among us we're actually gonna
do that this week we're gonna do that
Thursday at 12 a.m and I know it's early
that's because the Lord King got to
sleep you got to sleep I gotta get him
ready for will me Hood show we're going
to be doing that at 12 a.m I got P I got
BG he's gonna play with us I even got
Jack blue John he's gonna play it with
us I still got two spots open so if you
hit me up and I try to get Luca but Luca
like kind of like gave me the the Tucker
roll like she
hurry up before Sage come back
all right cool man so let's get this
pause get a body because we have gone
crazy long 12 a.m at 12 a.m what are you
12 p.m obviously oh it's at 12 a.m
usually at 12 a.m yeah 12 a.m I'll be at
work all right anyway
okay that was my we caught up one chance
so we caught up yeah let's get about it
do I help people in regards to the
recent bugs and Technical disparity
between PC nitrogen and console car
engine consoles with cyberpunk 2077.
what do you think CD projekt Red needed
to do in regards to its release date
choices are a delay again to fix
immersion breaking bucks
B can current gen versions completely
C delay the launch specifically with
next-gen patch or D yeah tripping all
you got to do is disable HDR frame rate
motion blur flavor
and then it's super lit shout out to all
those who are rocking the pole it will
go up later man yo salute the 5 000 my
brothers love a fantastic year
doing this thing man I'm proud of what
we're doing it's tremendous we got a lot
of stuff planned for next year we got
one more show I believe for the rest of
this year and it's it's been fun man
it's been a fun journey I love what
we're doing I love this community that
we we got you know super passionate even
when they hate being disagree
oh it's super pageant but yo just give
my shout outs and um for more for the
year and then we'll wrap up uh 2020 into
2021 Lord addict
oh we were talking about that all right
already
all right so so next week's gonna be a
little different unless something
drastic happens and I mean I mean
drastic Like It's gotta be like defining
that we need a normal show next week
we're gonna bring on guests we're going
to talk about this entire generation uh
you know we're gonna talk about our
favorite games the the games that are
honorable Mitch the games that got
looked over uh we're gonna do a little
bit differently next week so you know
definitely tune in for that and um you
know for next week for me only next week
I will be reading more in the chat
that's not uh you know that's not in
color uh so you know definitely keep a
lookout for that we're going to be
announcing some of the guests soon I
think cognito's already got a couple
planned out uh so you know definitely
look out for that it's it's going to be
a very interesting show save the life
it's gonna be the last one man Louisa
very uh very spicy today
I'm sending everyone a copy of a Pearl
Jam
the culture as heathens the culture can
I sell mine on eBay
after you listen to it do whatever you
want I'm gonna send you it I'm gonna
send you a digital copy action you can't
you have to keep it
so speaking of reading things that
aren't in color no red chillier says
farewell everyone be safe best wishes
and may solve Skywalker watch over you
unbelievable so uh
you know where I'm going you know what
I'm about to do go to work
um next week I saw my vacation so uh
Friday so I won't be able to be on a
attic stream on Thursday because I don't
start till Friday but I will be on the
bitcast uh nice along with Lord ains yes
on uh and our friend Dan Rodriguez
Saturday 1pm eastern time so I'm looking
forward to that because I've never been
on the big cast
yeah so that's what I'll be doing and
that's and we will be doing that stream
on the IOP Channel I saw people on a
couple people on Twitter asking where it
will be I don't want no one missing it
because I know everyone in this chat's
not sub to me so we'll be doing on the
iot so Anthony Boyd who didn't get back
to me on patreon on winning the question
a few weeks ago do we got some uh iron
Lord businesses
I'll get to you after the show all right
cool take care of it the Lannisters and
the Lords always pay their debts I I
kind of swore I got back to him we'll
make sure to get everything right we'll
square that up Lloyd King
rare form of the day as usual regular
five people find you what's going on oh
you can find me on Dolph Castle X
Fridays at 9 00 p.m talking about
premium
statue this week I got another unboxing
so uh this Maestro I did a live unboxing
on uh golf Castle let's go check that
out it's a half an hour you know you're
going there you just see me struggle
with this giant baby
um have yourself this is ridiculous
that's coming from the car the cover art
of imperfect future with uh the Maestro
I'm going to give you the Kos on that
that'll be up this week Kos live right
now talking about Gucci Man Battle of
the planets science
[Music]
all those uh wonderful uh characters
that y'all know and love uh this room is
going to change and you can catch me on
Twitter listen oh
I need you spitters those dudes who got
bars if you got bars hitting my DM on
Twitter that's King David OTW if you got
bars and you follow the realm and uh you
family hit me up yes we'll talk um I'm
trying to do something I need spitters
so once he looks at mine no one else is
Right attic ready so it's gonna be like
I got uh I got uh Talent or whatever
whatever that show is and uh only one
they can be only one or maybe maybe if
y'all so damn nice and I can't pick
maybe two versions of the joint and you
know I'm telling you right now you don't
want to miss out on this opportunity
because this opportunity will open doors
if you're spitting in the mirror you
driving to work you in the show you got
your bars hit me with those bars yeah
let's go let's go salute man yeah I can
say King out there moving and shaking
that Kingston please check it out also
up on launching gaming.net that got you
one it is fire he's got other stuff
cooking again appreciate your support
for last word I've been really showing
love man pulling up it's been growing I
love to see it you know what I'm saying
and um yeah man like I said one more
episode it'll be some fun you know
returning guests and just fun and
celebration and again thank everybody 5K
you couldn't have done it without you
guys you guys still rocking 300 over
y'all in here up to 500 a day hit that
like button share almost 300 likes dog
years
man yeah we really appreciate y'all have
nothing more to say that's all I got
addict you got everything we took care
of the business yeah um Anthony hit me
up on patreon I know
everyone enjoy your weekend catch y'all
next week
[Music]
foreign